Und damit herzlich willkommen zu einem weiteren Chaos Radio hier auf Fritz im Blue Moon. Am 29. Mai, dem letzten Donnerstag im Monat, erentert der Chaos Computer Club ja immer dieses Studio und ich stehen hier, darf Knöpfe drücken und Fragen stellen und es geht um ein Thema, dass die Welt bewegt oder bewegen sollte. Und heute geht es tatsächlich um ein Thema, was man könnte sozusagen auch kurz zusammenfassen unter Weltuntergang. Denn es gab in den vergangenen Monaten so ein paar Sicherheitslücken, die darüber hinausgingen, wie das, was man jetzt die Tage auch wieder gehört hat. Also Ebay sind so ein paar Millionen Passwort ab angekommen. Oder so ein paar Millionen Webserver sind offen. Das passiert manchmal. Aber da geht es um grundlegende technologische Lücken, die ganz schön fies sind. Und wo man sich vor allen Dingen fragt, wieso können die denn überhaupt entstehen? Weil die wurden doch eigentlich in diesem Biotop programmiert, von dem man immer sagt, das ist besonders sicher, denn da können ganz viele Leute darauf gucken. Open Source Software. Und das wollen wir heute alles mal in Ruhe klären. Und zu Gast dafür sind der Herr, der gerade schon so schön gehußtet hat, Herr Erdgeist, hallo und guten Tag.
Wunderschönen guten Abend.
Und ganz ohne Halserkrankung Dani Mohallon, guten Abend. So und im Vorfeld dieser Sendung, es ist ja immer ein bisschen schwierig beim Chaosradio, weil das Ziel ist es ja, einen schwierigen technologischen Sachverhalt, der unsere Gesellschaft nachhaltig beeinflussen kann, so zu erklären, dass jeder folgen kann, der am Anfang der Sendung noch keine Ahnung hatte. So die Theorie. Und ich möchte das schon gerne heute auch so halten, aber es gab im Vorfeld der Sendung ganz viele Fragen nach einem bestimmten Thema, weil es war schon klar, wir werden heute über Sicherheit reden und wir werden ein bisschen über Programmierung von Sicherheit reden und wie man diese Programmierung nachprüft und was Open Source damit zu tun hat. Aber es gibt so ein aktuelles Ereignis und das freut mich als Radiomenschen natürlich ganz besonders, ein aktuelles Ereignis und zwar geht es um True Crypt, was irgendwie kaputt oder verschwunden oder was auch immer ist. Und da wurde gefragt, ob wir auch mal drüber reden können. Und ich möchte, dass ihr jetzt gerne jemanden, der noch gar keine Ahnung von hat, was das überhaupt ist, erklärt, was da gerade los ist überhaupt. Was ist denn überhaupt True Crypt?
True Crypt ist eine Open Source Software, das heißt eine quelloffen geschriebene Software, wo jeder reingucken kann, die kryptographisch Festplatten auch für den Otto-Normal-Anwender verschlüsseln kann. Das heißt sowohl deine eigene eingebaute als auch externe Festplatten oder USB-Sticks, die du dir ranstecken kannst, die kann man damit so verschlüsseln, dass irgendjemand, der den Schlüssel nicht hat, an die Daten nicht rankommt.
Und diese Software ist deswegen so relativ bekannt, weil jedes Mal, wenn es in irgendeinem Computer-Magazin darum geht, wie verschlüsselt man denn den Festplatten? Da wird gesagt, naja, also Windows bringt das mit und US-10 bringt das mit und das gibt auch noch die anderen Möglichkeiten. Aber es gibt auch eine Open Source-Lösung, nämlich True Crypt. So und auf deren Webseite stand heute eine Meldung, die die Leute irritiert hat. Was stand da genau? Hat das jemand verfolgt?
Da stand heute, dass True Crypt sei ganz doll unsicher und man solle doch eine andere Software benutzen und da wären Fehler da drin und außerdem war plötzlich eine neue Version auf der Seite, die zwar auch kryptographisch signiert war mit einem validen Schlüssel, aber die ich hier deutlich nicht zum Installieren empfehlen würde. Weil? Weil davon auszugehen ist, dass der Server von jemandem Fremden übernommen worden ist und der hat da seinen Spaß mitgetrieben oder versucht, seine eigene Software dort unter die Leute zu bringen, die nicht das tut, was der Benutzer erwartet.
Ist das das, was du glaubst oder was jetzt so anerkannt der News Stand ist?
Das ist schon was ich glaube, aber was auch sehr wahrscheinlich ist.
Also es gibt verschiedene Gerüchte, wenn man mal so irgendwie Twitter oder so verfolgt. Aber wenn man sich mal überlegt, wie sehr man sich bemüht hat, um TrueCrypt jetzt gerade in den letzten Monaten, wir hatten auch letztes Mal beim Chaosradio 200, haben wir ja besprochen, dass es im Prinzip so ein zwei Phasen Audit gibt. Die erste Phase war abgeschlossen, jetzt wäre ein... Halt, halt, halt. Oh, ja, ja, ja. Ich wollte es nur ganz kurz ansprechen. Ich meine aber so sagen, da sind wir gerade heute im Thema drin, deswegen passt das aktuelle ganz gut. Audit heißt, jemand guckt sich diese Software an. Genau. Das ist ja das grundlegende Problem, über das wir heute reden wollen. Genau. Wann guckt sich jemand diese Software an? Und genau, bei TrueCrypt ist das halt so gewesen, wenn ich richtig informiert bin. Das ist halt diese Open Source Software. Das heißt, da kann man das angucken? Da könnte man es angucken. Da könnte man es angucken. Und da hat jetzt die Community oder irgendjemand mal hinsetzt und gesagt, lass uns das doch mal machen. Wie ist das von Schatten gegangen? Na ja, die Community hat erst mal gar nichts gemacht. Wenn ich das richtig verfolgt habe, ist es so gewesen, dass man also eine externe Firma, die sowas halt auch für Closed-House-Software macht, beauftragt hat, einen Bericht zu schreiben und sich das vorher anzugucken. Also die machen das auch für andere Software. Das sind nicht irgendwelche Leute, sondern da stehen dann halt auch die Namen derjenigen, die das machen, auch dran. Und die haben einfach einen Prüfbericht erst mal vorgelegt. Und dieser Prüfbericht sagt im Prinzip, wir haben uns noch nicht, wir haben uns erst mal die Software selber angeguckt. Wir haben nicht genau angeguckt, ob die Algorithmen, die zum Verschlüsseln verwendet werden, ob die korrekt sind. Aber davon ausgehen, dass sie korrekt sind, ist an diesem Programm Folgendes noch zu bemängeln. Und das muss noch abgestellt werden. Und das ist jetzt erst mal eine Aussage, mit der man hingehen kann und das Programm so weit gerade ziehen kann, dass man zumindest sagen kann, okay, wir haben uns quasi einem ersten Audit gestellt. Das Zweite ist natürlich noch viel komplizierter. Was wir schon wieder gelernt haben, ist, Software, die mit Computersicherheit zu tun hat, besteht aus zwei großen Komponenten. Nämlich einerseits muss die Mathematik, die dahintersteckt, die für Verschlüsselung benutzt wird, die muss sozusagen in Ordnung sein und auch in Ordnung programmiert sein. Und dann die eigentliche Software muss auch noch in Ordnung programmiert sein. Genau. Erdgeist. Was ist der schwierigere Teil zum Programmieren von diesen beiden Sachen?
Ich glaube grundsätzlich muss erst mal der Mathematiker, der dahin geht und da viel Hirnschmalz aufwendet, die mathematischen Algorithmen so dahin zu prügeln, dass sie dann wirklich mathematisch hart sind, dass also auch Kryptografen, die sich im selben Feld rumtreiben wie er, das nicht austricksen können, der muss am Ende Transferleistungen erbringen, dass er es schafft, sich in das Gehirn eines Programmierers hinein zu versetzen, der es dann schaffen muss, diese Software auch so umzusetzen, dass...
Okay, also das ist der komplizierte Teil?
Das ist der komplizierte Teil für den Mathematiker, der sich die Kryptographie ausgedacht hat. Für den Programmierer ist dann der komplizierte Teil, nicht irgendwelche Abkürzungen und was er gerne tut, Optimierungen zu nehmen, die er dann noch einbauen möchte, bei denen er dann Dinge falsch macht. Und außerdem müsste er im Optimalfall auch von der Kryptographie schon so viel Ahnung haben, dass er diverse Annahmen, von denen der Mathematiker ausgeht, die müsste er ja schon veräuferlicht haben.
Es gibt den einen Teil der Software, der geht es sozusagen nur um die Kryptographie. Und es gibt den anderen Teil, der geht es quasi um, was die Software so macht. Also irgendwie sieht das bunt aus.
Man kann auch schon bei dem kryptographischen Teil viele Programmierfehler machen.
Das war ja genau die Frage. Was ist der schwierigere Teil, der kryptographische Teil oder der Rest der Software?
Ich glaube die Kommunikation zwischen diesen beiden Teilen.
Vor allem die Kommunikation zwischen den Leuten, die das da umsetzen.
Magie! Wer ist dieser Mann? Guten Tag. Ein neuer Mann ist hinzugekommen. Er hört auf den Namen?
Florian.
Er hört auf den Namen Florian. Hallo Florian. Wo bist du denn hergekommen? Vom Draus vom Walde.
Vom Draus vom Walde von der S-Bahn, die noch ein harter Reset hatte beim Losfahren.
Ja, kaum ist der Chaos Computer Club irgendwo am Start. Geht irgendwas kaputt.
Ich war's nicht.
Jaja, das sagen sie dann hinterher immer alle. So, TrueCrypt. TrueCrypt ist also eine von diesen Geschichten, wo es im weitesten Sinne um Computersicherheit geht. Und es gibt jetzt noch zwei andere Fälle. Und die wollen wir auch in der ersten halben Stunde jetzt noch mal genauer erklären, was da eigentlich passiert ist, um dann im weiteren Verlauf der Sendung darauf hinauszukommen, wie das überhaupt passieren konnte und was man möglicherweise machen könnte, damit es nicht mehr oder nicht mehr in dieser Härte passiert und was das viel beschworene Open Source damit zu tun hat. So, jetzt gibt es ja zwei Sicherheitslücken, die, oder andersrum gesagt, es gibt ja im Internet diese eine Technologie, die irgendwie unser Netz sicherer macht. Das erkenne ich als normaler User oder sicherer machen soll. Lass es mich so sagen, ich runzle schon wieder mit der Stirn. Das erkennt man daran, dass das vorne, wenn ich im Browser was eingebe, HTTPS steht. So, dahinter steht eine Technologie, die heißt wahlweise SSL oder TLS oder sonst irgendwie. Und da gab es in der jüngeren Vergangenheit zwei fiese Sicherheitslücken. Und ich weiß gar nicht, was die bekanntere war. Ich vermute fast die bekanntere war die Go-To-Fail-Lücke, weil die Apple getroffen hat. Und da war natürlich sozusagen das Geschrei groß, dass man da mal so richtig schön drauf rumhacken kann, dass Apple auch mal um sich ist. Kann jemand mal zusammenfassen, was Go-To-Fail war? Go-To-Fail war ein Programmierfehler, der mit dem Go-To-Befehl tatsächlich zu tun hat. Also wer vielleicht mal sich alleine irgendwie mal Pascal oder Basic oder so in der Schule gelernt hat, kennt das möglicherweise. Und was dieser Go-To-Befehl halt tut, ist, ich kann damit beliebig im Programmcode herumspringen. Normalerweise habe ich einen sehr strukturierten Ablauf. Ich bestimme also genau, was passiert. Und dieser Go-To ist im Prinzip, ich kann eine beliebige Sprungmarke irgendwo hinsetzen, also ziemlich überall hin und das passiert dann. Das Go-To wird wahlweise, je nachdem, wen man fragt, als sehr schädlich angesehen, weil es eben diesen Programmfluss beliebig beeinflussen kann. Aber das war hier gar nicht der Knackpunkt, sondern der Knackpunkt war, dass zwei hintereinander folgende Gotos kamen. Und dazu muss man jetzt eine Eigenheit von C, glaube ich.
Ich glaube, das kann man, wie Menschen verständlich erklären, ist, dass eine Einrückung üblicherweise dazu da ist, jemanden, der auf den Code draufguckt, ein Gefühl dafür zu vermitteln, was dieser Code tut. Das heißt, man macht so konditionale Dinge, die...
Wenn eine Bedingung da ist, mache ich was. Das rückt man dann nach rechts ein, damit man weiß, dass es in diese Bedingungen reingehört.
Und wenn man zwei Dinge nacheinander einrückt, dann geht man davon aus, dass die beide auf derselben semantischen Ebene sind und wie das wie beide immer nur konditional passieren. Aber wenn die Einrückung fieserweise nicht das widerspiegelt, was der Code tut, dann hat man das Problem, dass jemand, der draufguckt, flüchtig nur, davon ausgeht, das wird schon seine Richtigkeit haben und kann nicht so viel Schlimmes passieren.
Aber was war denn der Fehler?
Dass beim Überprüfen von dem gegenüber präsentierten Credentials, wie heißt das, Schlüsselmaterial, Ausweise quasi. Ja, das beim Ausweise prüfen, musst du dir vorstellen, da geht der daher, wenn du beim Fördner vorbei kommst. Du wirfst ihm so einen Ausweis hin und der ist so händisch mit Wunschstiften bemalt, dann geht der Fördner erst mal und sagt, du, nee, das sieht schon mal gar nicht wie ein Ausweis aus, kommst du hier nicht durch. Und dann macht er so einen mehrstufigen Programm, checkt er erst, ob's grob so aussieht, dann guckt er, ob der Ausweis überhaupt für die Firma ist, wo der rein möchte, dann guckt er, ob der noch gültig ist und tut da so 20, 30 Checks, bevor er sich dann mal wirklich dich dann durchlässt. Und was der Fördner dann blöderweise gemacht hat, war, bei einem der ersten Checks schon sich zu merken, ja, im Zweifel ist erstmal alles in Ordnung und nur wenn hier unterwegs was nicht in Ordnung ist, dann lass ich nicht durch. Hat aber gleich beim allerersten Check, oh, ist mit Buntstiften, hat er gesagt, dann geh ich mal nach unten in die Stelle, wo ich ihn nicht rauslasse, hat aber sich das interne Häkchen, ich lass ihn nicht durch, noch nicht gesetzt und ist jetzt unten an der Aufräumroutine, sagt, und jetzt muss ich mal den ganzen Kram, den ich mir zurechtgeschrieben hab, muss ich mal in den Mülleimer werfen und guck jetzt nach, soll ich ihn durchlassen? Ja, den soll ich durchlassen. Obwohl der ja gerade irgendwie nur mit einem per Buntstifte gemahlenen Häkchen vorbei ist.
Der Wachmann hat zu sagen, hat so ein Klemmbritt, wo er eine ellenlange Liste hat, welche Häkchen er alle machen muss. Und ganz zum Anfang findet er etwas, was eigentlich sagt, der Typ kann eigentlich nicht durch, macht sich das Kreuz aber nicht, blättet die Liste bis zum Ende, guckt wo überall Kreuzchen gemacht hat, sieht er, kein Kreuzchen kann er durch. So und das war ja aber spezifisch für Apple, oder?
Das ist zwar, na Apple macht ja die Software in so einem Publisher-Source. Das ist nicht wirklich offen und frei, wie die für andere Betriebssysteme wie Linux oder FreeBSD zum Beispiel, sondern bringt dann einige Projekte wirklich in Open Source, andere nur in publizierten Source Codes und da kann man reingucken. Und dort war der Fehler in deren eigentlich, um eine schlimme, weitverbreitete Kryptografie-Bibliothek namens OpenSSL mal zu ersetzen, hat sich Apple hingesetzt und eine eigene Bibliothek geschrieben. Heißt Common Crypto und macht drumrum noch ein paar mehr Bibliotheken, die da drauf angewiesen sind. Und genau in dieser Bibliothek, in dem sie eigentlich alles besser machen wollten, modernere Programmierstandards mal einfließen lassen, da haben sie dann diesen Fehler wahrscheinlich beim...
Aber die Frage war, das betrifft nur Apple dieser Fehler?
Kommt drauf an. Diese Bibliothek kann man sich als jeder runterladen und kompilieren und ausführen, aber sehr wahrscheinlich ist es, dass es nur Apple-Benutzer betrifft.
Also theoretisch könnte es sozusagen andere, dort könnten andere diesen Programmiercode benutzen, aber es macht wahrscheinlich keiner. Deswegen vor allem Apple-User davon betroffen.
Ich weiß nicht, am Ende ist es nicht so leicht, gute Bibliotheken, die einem Kryptografie zu machen, zu bekommen. Einige wollen Geld dafür haben, andere kommen mit Lizenzen, die man in eigenen Projekten nicht benutzen möchte. Und ich finde eigentlich ist das, was Apple da sich zusammengeschrieben hat, von der Programmierschnittstelle für einen Programmierer, der es richtig machen möchte, schon gar nicht so doof. Also ich kann mir vorstellen, dass es da einfach auch Leute gibt, die das benutzen.
Also das haben wir jetzt schon die zweite Sache gelernt, über Software die Computersicherheit umsetzen kann. Nämlich, einer des besteht sich aus zwei Teilen. Nämlich der Teil, der wirklich für die Verschlüsselung zuständig ist und dem ganzen Rest, der die Software dann schön und benutzbar macht. Und zweitens, dieser Teil, der für die Umsetzung der Verschlüsselung zuständig ist, den kann man sich auch von woanders nehmen, wenn das schon mal jemand gut gemacht hat und dann quasi in seine eigene Software reinbauen. Korrekt?
Das ist korrekt. Es ist natürlich so, du möchtest nicht, dass jeder sich seine eigene Krypto-Bibliothek schreibt. Da kann man echt viel falsch machen, weil wie gesagt, es ist eine hochkomplexe Materie und unterwegs kann man neben den Programmierfehlern, die dann dazu führen, dass jemand Fremdes mein Computer übernimmt, gibt es auch lauter Dinge, die dann Schlüsselmaterial nach draußen liegen, sagt man üblicherweise. Das heißt, dass wenn man sich blöd anstellt und für einige Operationen ein bisschen länger braucht als für andere Operationen, dann kann ein Angreifer zum Beispiel einzelne Bits des geheimen Schlüssels rauslesen. Das will man alles vermeiden, deswegen benutzt man üblicherweise abgehangene Software, wo man zumindest davon ausgeht, dass andere Leute, die ein bisschen schlauer sind, als man selber da schon öfter länger und intensiver drauf geguckt hat.
Also das ist quasi so was wie, wenn ich ein Auto baue, baue ich nicht ein neues Gurtsystem rein, sondern ich benehme den 3-Punkt-Gurt, weil der hat es jetzt gut erwiesen und der funktioniert auch. Und Volvo hat damals, glaube ich, sogar auch das Patent freigegeben, damit alle das machen können. Aber ganz andere Geschichte. Der Punkt ist also, es gibt diesen Teil der Software, die die Verschüssung umsetzt und den holt man sich am besten von jemandem, der Ahnung hat. Das heißt aber, dass dieser Teil, den man sich von jemandem anders holt, natürlich besonders gut sein muss. Also das muss quasi Qualitätsarbeit sein.
Also ist es besser. Er muss dann auch noch ansprechend dem Programmierer es leicht machen, es richtig zu machen und es falsch zu machen möglichst schwer. Das ist, wo sich viele bibliotheken...
Drei Punkt gut, nicht verkehrt drum einbauen.
Beispiel, das braucht alles irgendwie Zufall. Und ein ganz beliebter Fehler ist, dass ich den Zufall, den ich in so eine Bibliothek, die ich herfertig kriege, aus einer nicht zufälligen Quelle hole, wie der Sekunden seit dem Einschalten des Rechners. Das ist bei Embedded-Geräten oft ein Problem.
Okay, warte, also die Zufall, also die Mathematik, die Verschlüsselung möglich macht, die braucht an manchen Stellen eine zufällige Zahl und wichtig ist, dass die wirklich zufällig ist.
Richtig. Und wenn ich so ein Embedded-Gerät habe, was ich so im Elektronikmarkt kaufe, die keine Uhr drin haben, dann zählen die üblicherweise die Sekunden seit dem Einschalten.
Und wenn ein Angreifer dieses dann angreift, dann kann er einfach sagen, okay, ich merke mal einfach, wie er an das Gerät eingeschaltet hat. Das ist noch schlimmer.
Es ist noch schlimmer, die Geräte starten halt und das erste, was sie machen, ist dann beim Hochfahren zum Beispiel so ein SSH-Key sich ausrechnen. Und weil die alle noch keine Uhrzeit haben, weiß man das bei allen diesen Routern zum Beispiel, die ja innerhalb der ersten zehn Minuten nach dem Einschalten diesen Key erzeugt haben und dann ist diese Zufallszahl also in einem bestimmten Bereich und dann ist das alles nicht mehr wirklich zufällig.
Noch schlimmer, die Anzahl der Sekunden seit 1970 sind in einem Bereich, den man mit dem Computer noch ganz leicht einmal durchzählen kann. Das heißt, man kann sich alle Keys, die nur das Datum als geheimen Schlüssel dahernehmen, die kann man einfach mal so jede einzelne Sekunde durchzählen, sich den Schlüssel einmal generieren, kostet nicht signifikant Zeit und kann dann vergleichen, ob man mit dem das entschlüsseln kann.
Das ist jetzt sozusagen das Problem, wenn andere Leute das Software weiterverwenden. Man kriegt die fertige Verschlüsselungssoftware und die Verschlüsselungssoftware sagt dem Programmierer, okay Programmierer, an dieser Stelle musst du eine zufällige Zahl reinwerfen und dann gibt der Programmierer irgendwas hinein und wenn er da nicht ordentlich ist sozusagen und eine ordentliche zufällige Zahl gibt, dann ist es egal, wie gut die Verschlüsselung ist, dann hat er es falsch benutzt und ist kaputt.
Zugegeben, das Problem ist aber auch nicht leicht. Du musst dir vorstellen, so ein Computer ist eine Maschine, die genau dafür gebaut wird, deterministisch aus den gleichen Eingaben immer dieselben Ausgaben zu erzeugen. Möglichst wenig Zufall soll dabei passieren. Das heißt, du musst dir schon am Anfang wirklich Kopf darum machen, wo du denn jetzt wirklich soliden Zufall herbekommst. Also was man üblicherweise tut, ist, ein Mikrofon zu nehmen und das Rauschen.
Mein Computer belauscht mich? Was, was, was?
Nen Widerstand. Es gibt ja so thermisches Rauschen.
Wir entfernen uns gerade so ein bisschen, weil wir reden ja über Sicherheitssoftware.
Ich finde das ist wichtig. Ich würde den Bogen gerade wieder zurückschlagen, dass...
Übrigens, was ich noch sagen wollte, falls ihr in irgendeiner Stelle irgendwas nicht versteht, dann macht bitte das hier. 0331 70 97 110 Denn ich versuche im Laufe dieser Sendung die geneigten Gäste vom Chaos Computer Club immer so weit im Zaum zu halten, dass sie die Erklärung in einer Art und Weise abliefern, damit sie jeder versteht, der Anfang der Sendung noch keine Ahnung davon hatte. Und möglicherweise gelingt man das nicht immer und dann müsst ihr wirklich anrufen. 0331 70 97 110 Das ist wohl anders. Also ich brauche eure Hilfe. Ich meine, die sind zu dritt. Ich bin alleine. Hilfe!
Kriegen wir denn Erklär-Bär-Bienchen?
Ja.
Sehr gut. So, jetzt haben wir da beschrieben, es gibt also diese ähm, es gibt also diese verschiedenen Teile in der Software. Und bei dem Go-To-Fail-Bug wurde, würde man sagen, wurde genau so eine dieser Softwares halt, da wurde was falsch gemacht. Das heißt sozusagen schon die Grundlage für Verschlüsselung war im Arsch, wenn ich das mal so salopp formulieren darf.
Also bitte, das ist eine Familien-Sendung.
Und dann hatten wir, nein ist das nicht, und dann haben wir noch eine dritte Sache, die wir sprechen, das ist sogenannte Heartbleed. Schaffen wir das noch in sechs Minuten? So, dann mal los. Florian, du bist der Neue.
Was ist Heartbleed? Heartbleed war ein Bug, in dem man nach dem Aufbauen der Verbindung den Server regelmäßig gefragt hat, bist du noch, da lebst du noch. Da gibt es einen schönen XK-CD zu. Man schickt eine Nachricht hin und schickt dann da so ein Hallo hin und sagt, das waren jetzt so sechs Zeichen. Gib mir die doch mal zurück, wenn die ankommen, ist alles gut, der Server lebt noch. Wenn man aber gesagt hat, ich schick dir sechs Zeichen, hallo, und möchte aber 30 haben, dann kommen 30 zurück oder 512. Und dummerweise waren in diesem Speicherbereich halt dann zum Beispiel die entschlüsselten E-Mails, wenn es ein E-Mail-Server war.
Ich versuch's nochmal in meinen Worten zu erklären, ob ich's richtig verstanden hab. Sag, ob ich recht hatte. Also A ist diese Verbindung überhaupt, wozu ist die da? Es gibt Verschlüsselung. Und diese Verschlüsselung zwischen zwei Geräten wird aufgebaut, also die Verbindung. Das ist quasi wie ein Anruf.
Das ist wie ein Anruf.
Könnte man so sagen. Und weil ja sozusagen beim Anruf, wenn der andere nichts mehr sagt, fragt man ab und zu, Bist du noch da? So. Und das macht man, für die Art und Weise, man sagt, man schickt ein Wort hin, und schickt gleichzeitig die Länge des Wortes hin. Und dann soll der gegenüberliegende, der gegenüber irgendeinem Partner, soll dann sagen, bei sich nachgucken.
Gib mir doch mal die ersten fünf Zeichen, oder die ersten fünf Worte von dem Text, den ich dir gesagt habe.
Dann kann ich dabei ein Schwätzer machen. Wieder mit so einem, jemandem, dem man einen Brief schreibt und sagt, sag mal, ich hab da irgendwo meine Akte rumhängen, kannst du mir nicht die ersten vier Seiten aus meiner Akte nach Hause schicken? So, legst du auf einen Kopierer und gibst sie mir. So. Und wenn man jetzt fieserweise einen Brief hinschreibt und sagt, sag mal, kannst du mir nicht die nächsten 64.000 Seiten auch noch kopieren? Und der Büroangestellte da nicht drüber nachdenkt, sondern einfach, hör wohl, nimmt sich dann die Akte und wenn deine Akte zu Ende ist, nimmt er sich die nächste Akte, kopiert er auch wieder, und bis er wie viele 64.000 Seiten hat, schickt sie dir noch mal eine.
Du sagst im Prinzip, ey du, mein letzter Brief war doch 64.000 Seiten lang, schick mal bitte rüber, ich will mal vergleichen, ob das richtige Ergebnis angekommen ist.
Genau, so ungefähr.
Und dann sagt er das gegenüber, ja, deine geheimen Passworte sind übrigens.
Ja, also nicht nur deine, die von den anderen Leuten in dem Rest von den anderen Akten.
Ja, also man kann quasi den gesamten Schrank durchlesen. Genau. Okay, so das sind, also das haben wir über drei wichtige Softwares, Softwareen, Programmierteile, Dinge gesprochen, die wichtig sind für Computersicherheit.
Programme.
Und Kommunikationssicherheit und Sicherheit im Netz. Und alle drei sind Open Source. Ja, mehr oder weniger. Naja, also man kann bei allen drei, also der wichtige Punkt ist, man kann bei allen drei Sachen sehen, wie der Programmiercode dazu aussieht.
Was war denn der erste?
Das heißt, wenn jemand, der Ahnung hat, dort reinguckt, kann der möglicherweise sehen, oder könnte der erkennen, dass da ein Fehler vorliegt. Und einer der großen, großen, großen Vorteile von Open Source, der zumindest immer wieder angepriesen wird, ist, dass die Leute sagen, ja, da können ganz viele Leute reingucken und deswegen wird immer irgendjemand den Fehler finden und es wird nie ein Fehler drin vorkommen. Given enough eyeballs, all bugs are shallow. Jetzt bitte nochmal in Deutsch.
Wenn nur noch Leute draufglotzen, dann gehen Fehler schon kaputt.
Also gefunden haben wir es ja jetzt auch.
Das ist so ein bisschen wie mit der Demokratie. Am Ende, ja klar, so ihr könnt in die Ausschüsse alle reinkommen, setzt euch dazu, schreibt mit und ist halt Arbeit.
Ist halt Arbeit. Also wir wollen gleich mal sagen, das ist das, was wir jetzt im Rest der Sendung nochmal erklären wollen. Wie funktioniert das wirklich? Theoretisch gibt es diese Open Source Software. Theoretisch könnten da Leute reingucken. Theoretisch ist sie total sicher, weil theoretisch ganz viele Leute die Fehler gefunden haben. Praktisch und das haben wir jetzt in der ersten halben Stunde gezeigt, ist das nicht passiert. Wie das klappen kann, das erklären wir wie gesagt gleich. Jetzt gibt es erst noch eine kleine Musik, dann machen wir Nachrichten und dann sind wir wieder da.
Wir präsentieren euch diesen Sommer. Das Cosmonaut-Festival. Das Splash-Festival. Mit Kolega, Outkast und Whiskalifa. Das Helene Beach-Festival. Mit Alligator, Jennifer Rostock und Cro. Und das sind längst noch nicht alle. Tickets für diese und jede Menge andere. Teilweise schon längst ausverkaufte Festivals. Könnt ihr bei Fritz gewinnen. Montag bis Freitag. Immer um 7 und 17 Uhr bei den Radio-Fritzen. Fritz.de slash Festivals. Raus aus dem Alltag, rein in den Sommer.
Fritz.
Die französische Regierung korrigiert ihre Politik. Der Grund ist der Sieg des Rechtsextremen Front National bei der Europawahl. Jetzt wird das geplante Ausländerwahlrecht auf Kommunalebene doch nicht eingeführt. Präsident Hollande hatte eine entsprechende Gesetzesänderung im letzten Wahlkampf versprochen. Doch dafür fehle jetzt der Rückhalt in der Politik, hieß es aus Paris. Bei der Europawahl wurde die rechtsextreme Partei stärkste Kraft in Frankreich. Hollande-Sozialisten mussten eine Schloppe hinnehmen. Der Bürgerkrieg hat die syrische Wirtschaft völlig ruiniert. Die Bevölkerung sei verarmt, das steht in einem Bericht der UNO. Die Arbeitslosigkeit ist demnach seit dem Jahr 2011 von 10 auf 54 Prozent hochgeschossen. Weniger als die Hälfte der Kinder in Syrien geht noch zur Schule. Beobachter schätzen, dass bis April 2014 mindestens 150.000 Menschen getötet wurden. Die Europäische Union hat ihre Sanktion gegen syrische Firmen und Vertraute von Machthaber Assad heute um ein Jahr verlängert. In der Ostukraine ist weiter gekämpft worden. Die Übergangsregierung in Kiew sagt, dass Bewaffnete in der Region Lugansk versucht haben, eine Kaserne zu stürmen. In der Stadt Donetsk sollen Milizen gegen Flünderer vorgegangen sein. Eine Bestätigung von unabhängiger Seite gibt es nicht. In der Nähe von Slaviansk haben pro-russische Separatisten einen Hubschrauber abgeschossen. Dabei sind 12 Soldaten der Übergangsregierung getötet worden, darunter auch ein General. YouTube muss in der Türkei wieder für alle Internetnutzer erreichbar sein. Die Sperrung der Videoplattform sei nicht rechtens, das hat das türkische Verfassungsgericht angeordnet. Die Sperre verletzte das Recht auf freie Meinungsäußerung. Es ist die zweite Niederlage für Ministerpräsident Erdogan vor dem Verfassungsgericht. Dieses hatte bereits Anfang April entschieden, dass die Blockade von Twitter aufgehoben werden muss. Die Regierung hatte Twitter und YouTube Ende März sperren lassen, weil dort Korruptionsvorwürfe gegen Erdogan und sein Umfeld aufgetaucht waren. Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen in Berlin-Köpen nickt sieben, in Charlottenburg noch acht Grad, in Europin auch nur noch sieben, Potsdam acht, Frankfurt und Manch nur neun Grad. In der Nacht klart der Himmel auf, bei acht bis fünf Grad minimal. Morgen scheint dann die Sonne, im Tagesverlauf bilden sich aber auch Quellwolken und aus denen kann es dann auch regnen, in Odernähe auch gewittern. Dazu gibt es dann 21 Grad maximal. Gleich nach Brandenburg auf die A9, Berlin Richtung Halle Leipzig. Zwischen Beelitz Heilstätten und Beelitz hat es einen Unfall mit einem Laster gegeben. A10, westlicher Berliner Ring, Richtung Dreieck Werder. Der Anschluss Lest, ist wegen Bauarbeiten noch bis morgen Abend gesperrt. Und A13, Dresden Richtung Berlin, zwischen Ruhland und Schwarzheide, da liegen Gegenstände auf der linken Spur. Wo immer ihr seid, gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBW.
Und wenn ihr den Fritz Night Flight von letzter nach verpasst habt oder ihn einfach noch mal hören wollt, dann hört ihn doch einfach noch mal, so oft ihr wollt und wann ihr wollt. Eine Woche lang im Musikstream auf fritz.de.
Hallo, guten Tag. Mein Name ist Marcus Richter. Und ich bin heute nicht allein im Studio, denn es ist Blue Moon im Chaos Radio. Zu Gast sind vom Chaos Computer Club in Reihenfolge ihres Erscheins Erdgeist, Florian und Danimo. So, es geht heute um sichere Software und die Frage, warum sie nicht so sicher ist, wie wir eigentlich alle gerne hätten. Angefangen hat das, das haben wir in der letzten halben Stunde erklärt, dass es gerade drei prominente Beispiele gibt, nämlich TrueCrypt und zwei Fehler, die den Namen GoToField und Heartbleed tragen, die alle irgendwie, also so Basisgrundlagen der sicheren Computertechnik, der sicheren Kommunikation eigentlich liefern sollen, aber dann doch irgendwie kaputt waren und das, obwohl sie Open Source waren. Open Source fragt ihr euch, ja was hat das jetzt mit sicherer Computertechnik zu tun? Na ja, ist ganz einfach. Es ist so, dass da theoretisch alle reingucken können, das heißt, theoretisch können alle die Fehler finden, die drin sind. Es hat aber nur keiner gemacht. Wir wollen heute klären, warum das so ist und was man möglicherweise dagegen tun könnte. Ich will aber vorher noch mal ein bisschen nachfragen, warum diese Fehler, die jetzt aufgetreten sind, überhaupt so krass sind. Also diese letzten beiden, dieses Go-To-Fail und dieses Heartbleed, das betrifft ja die sogenannten sicheren Kommunikationsverbindungen, also was ihr im Browser als HTTPS kennt. Und das, also kann man natürlich sagen, okay, das ist jetzt schlimm, weil beim Online-Banking kann mir jemand zuhören, aber dieses HTTPS, das spielt doch wahrscheinlich noch, oder diese sicheren Verbindungen spielen noch eine viel größere Rolle wahrscheinlich. Wo werden die denn überall angewendet, wo man sie vielleicht auch als Anwender gar nicht sieht? Ich denke an sowas wie Updates vielleicht oder...
Ja, eigentlich überall. Also inzwischen sind unverschlüsselte Verbindungen ein graues Relikt. Also in meiner Blase kommen unverschlüsselte Verbindungen gar nicht mehr vor. Ich schütze meine Kommunikationswege zu meinem Server natürlich mit SSH, was noch ein ähnliches Protokoll ist, aber ansonsten bieten alle meine Server Dienste, bei denen man sich anmelden muss, nur über eine verschlüsselte Verbindung an. Das heißt, so...
E-Mails abholen, E-Mails senden, der ganze Kram.
Und wenn das jetzt sagen, also was würde passieren, wenn das jetzt einfach alles offen ist? Also was ist zu sagen, was ist das Worst-Case-Szenario fürs ganze Internet?
Fürs ganze Internet könnte irgendjemand, der sich, also jetzt bei Heartbleed zum Beispiel, könnte jemand, der den Server nach Speicher befragt, großen Stil, und der Server rückt seine privaten Schlüssel raus, dann könnte ein Angreifer sämtliche jemals aufgenommenen Verbindungen wieder entschlüsseln. Das heißt, wenn der Server nicht durch Zufall eine Protokoll-Erweiterung namens Perfect Forward Security angeschaltet hat, dann kann jemand ganz bequem, der im selben Rechenzentrum ist wie der Server, den er angreifen möchte, hat er mal eine Weile lang seinen Datenverkehr komplett mitgeschnitten, um mal zu gucken, ob er es irgendwann verwenden kann. Und plötzlich sieht er, dass bei dem Server der geheime Schlüssel zu holen ist und kann damit sämtliche Verbindungen nachträglich entschlüsseln, ohne die Einwilligung der Kommunikationspartner zu haben und kann dann alles rausholen, was da drin passiert ist. Seien es E-Mails oder Nachrichten oder Google Docs oder vergleichbare kollaborative Werkzeuge, kann er schauen, was dort Leute beschrieben haben. Was besonders heikel ist, wenn es zum Beispiel eine Firma ist, die dort Strategiepapiere zusammengeschrieben hat. Aber E-Mails sind ja auch schon schlimm genug.
Oder eben Zugangspasswörter, die da per E-Mail verschickt werden, bei Account-Aktivierung und Registrierung und Passwort-Zurücksetzen, ähnliche Dinge.
Im Prinzip sind alle Informationen öffentlich. Also die Sicherheit ist ja auch immer so, entweder sie funktioniert oder sie funktioniert nicht. So ein bisschen gibt es da nicht, ne?
Man kann schon Dinge immer ein bisschen sicherer machen gegen einen dedizierten Angreifer.
Ich meine, wir reden ja heute über Fehler in der Software. Wenn eine Verschlüsselungssoftware einen Fehler hat, dann ist die kaputt.
Dann ist die zwar kaputt, aber dann hat man danach immer noch verschiedene Impacts, also verschiedene Möglichkeiten, was man damit machen kann. Also einfach den Server immer wieder zum Abstürzen zu bringen, ist halt so eine Denial-of-Service-Attacke. Das ist das eine, was man machen kann. Das andere ist, dass man verhindern kann, dass jemand mit dem Server redet, ja, auch eine DOS-Attacke. Oder eben sich als derjenige ausgeben oder Signaturen fälschen nachträglich. Das heißt, man unterschreibt dann mit dem Namen des Servers irgendwas. Wenn man zum Beispiel Software abholt, wie zum Beispiel TrueCrypt, und hat die Möglichkeit mit einem validen Geheimenschlüssel die Software zu unterschreiben.
Also was passiert ist quasi, ich gehe zum Server und sage so, du bitte lass mich mal diese Software runterladen, die mich total sicher macht. Und dann sagt der Server, der halt nicht der wirkliche ist, der sagt einfach so, ja bitte lade doch diese Software herunter, die ist total sicher. Und ist dann quasi gefälscht. Und das Tolle ist, das Betriebssystem behauptet auch noch, dass sie total sicher ist, weil die Software selber, egal über welchen Kanal du die bezogen hast, wird heutzutage bei fast allen Betriebssystemen digital signiert. Das bedeutet, da packst du nochmal eine Unterschrift drunter. Okay, und das ist dann so, aha, schön. Das sind ja schöne Optionen, die da rausgegangen sind. Und da möchte man noch meinen, da hätten sich dann Leute hingestellt und gesagt, so ja, wir gucken uns das mal an, dass das wirklich sicher ist. Jetzt frage ich euch jetzt gleich, warum ist das nicht passiert oder wollt ihr lieber erst mal erklären, wie das denn überhaupt normalerweise vor sich geht bei so Software? Also ich hab so rudimentäre Programmierversuche unternommen und die haben mir immer so weit gereicht, bis mein Lieblingsbeispiel, da hab ich mal versucht, automatisch herauszufinden, ob etwas bestimmtes auf der Seite heute.de gepostet wird. Habe dann einen Fehler gemacht, der dazu geführt hat, dass mein Webserver Unmengen von Traffic verursacht und dann abgeschaltet wurde irgendwann. Und das ist sozusagen das, was ich von programmieren kann. Man macht halt irgendwas und wenn es läuft, dann lässt man es sozusagen in die freie Wildbahn. Ich kann mir das jetzt vorstellen. Bei Sicherheitssoftware ist das ein bisschen anders.
Also das Problem Heartbleed hat ja eine Programmierbibliothek namens OpenSSL betroffen. Und diese Programmierbibliothek ist ursprünglich entstanden, als sich ein gewisser Lee hingesetzt hat und gemeint, ich muss mal herausfinden, wie das mit dieser Mathematik mit großen Zahlen überhaupt funktioniert. Ich will mal gucken, was passiert, wenn meine Zahlen jetzt nicht wie in der Schulbuch Mathematik, sowas wie 3, 4 oder 5 Stellen haben, sondern sowas wie Tausende von Stellen. Denn muss ja irgendwie Addition, Multiplikation, Subtraktion, Wurzel ziehen, muss ja auch funktionieren. Hat das aber probiert, hat sich hingesetzt, hat ein paar Funktionen geschrieben und war dann am Ende ganz zufrieden, hat gesagt, hey, super, jetzt kann ich mit richtig großen Zahlen hantieren.
Warte mal, ist OpenSSL nicht eine von diesen Softwarestücken, die dafür sorgen soll, dass Internetkommunikation sicherer wird? Du sagst, es ist so eine Art elaborierter Taschenrechner?
Na, die kryptographischen Primitiven, also die Funktionen, die man dazu benutzt, die basieren eigentlich immer darauf, dass man Mathematik macht mit echt großen Zahlen, sodass irgendjemand, der versucht, alle Zahlen durchzuprobieren, länger braucht, als das Universum bestehen wird. So, das ist... Grundsätzlich, wenn dir ein Kryptograph sagt, so, das ist schon sicher, dann ist es ja keine absolute Ansage, sondern eine Wahrscheinlichkeitsansage. Er sagt, natürlich kann man jede Kryptographie brechen, du brauchst halt nur ewig, wenn du es durchprobierst. Und so gehen Mathematiker daher und sagen, na gut, dann nehmen wir mal eine Zahl, die so riesengroß ist, dass du mit allen Computern auf der Welt länger brauchst, als das Universum existiert. Und dann bist du schon auf der sicheren Seite. Und dazu brauchst du aber echt große Zahlen.
Okay, aber jetzt hat dieser Typ also einen elaborierten Taschenrechner gebaut und festgestellt, das kann man auch für Sicherheit benutzen.
Jetzt hat der Typ einen elaborierten Taschenrechner geschrieben und gesehen, dass wenn man Kryptographie machen muss, braucht man einen elaborierten Taschenrechner. Hey, hat er sich gedacht, dann mach ich mal das bisschen, das bisschen, was man dann braucht, um so eine Kryptographiebibliothek zu machen, mach ich mal auch noch. Und dann hat der... Es gab es halt zu der Zeit so in Opens House, nicht? Und alle anderen, ey super, da ist ein elaborierter Taschenrechner, ich würde auch gerne Kryptographie machen, lass uns doch mal...
Wann war das?
80er Jahre? 90er? Nein, 90er Jahre.
Ich will nur so ein Haus noch mal, also so 20 Jahre her. Man muss ja wissen, OpenSSL ist derzeit einer der Grundbausteine. Oder bis vor diesem großen Fehler war es das zumindest. Also viele Leute, die irgendwas mit sicherer Kommunikation im Netz machen, also jetzt nicht alle, aber schon viele, nutzen dieses Ding. Das ist sozusagen so ein Standard, oder nicht?
Das ist so ein Standardding, weil es einfach wenig Alternativen gibt. Und weil ich ja vorhin schon andeutete, dass man beim Implementieren so viel falsch machen kann, dass man lieber darauf vertraut, dass andere Leute das schon richtig gemacht haben, oder dass man sich dann, wenn so ein Projekt anschließt, und dann damit programmiert. Also gibt's da gerade eigentlich nur so 5 oder 6 Lösungen. Einige sind von Regierungen finanziert, einige sind von Microsoft, ich meine, eine ist von Microsoft, eine ist von Apple gemacht worden, dann gibt es eine, heißt GnuTLS, die ist vom Gnu Linux Projekt. Das ist so ungefähr wo die herkommen. Es braucht das schon, dann... Früher hat man sich hemmsarmlich hingestellt, ich hab schon gesagt, machen wir mal einfach. Und heutzutage wird sowas denn, wenn von einer größeren Organisation angestoßen, die auch Programmierer...
Genau. Und die macht das wahrscheinlich nicht Open Source. Oder sind so Verschüttelungsbibliotheken...
Nö, GnuTLS ist irgendwie dann Open Source. Und dann gibt es eine Bibliothek, die von der belgischen Regierung gesponsert worden ist, heißt PolaSSL, die sieht, wie ich finde, ganz cool aus. Und die haben sich auch hingesetzt, mit dem Anspruch, mathematisch durchzubeweisen, dass die Software genau das tut, was sie angeblich tun soll, was andere Programmierbibliotheken nicht liefern.
Aber zurück zu OpenSSL. Das ist vor 20 Jahren geschrieben worden, ist eigentlich so ein gewisses Experiment gewesen. Hat sich dann sehr groß verbreitet, weil es gab kaum andere Sachen. Das heißt sozusagen, das Beste, was man in diesem Bereich hatte, war ein ausgearbeitetes Experiment. Und das war aber Open Source Software. Das heißt, im Prinzip konnte da jeder reingucken. Jetzt frage ich mich, warum ist das nicht passiert? Warum ist nicht irgendwann mehr mit hingegangen, dass so krass, diese Software wird so häufig von so vielen Leuten benutzt, die muss man doch mal kontrollieren, ob die funktioniert.
Na, erstmal weißt du ja nicht, ob nicht andere Leute reingeguckt haben, gedacht haben, oh super.
Ja, richtig, aber wenn ich das nicht weiß, also sozusagen, wenn ich mich in ein Auto hineinsetze, dann möchte ich doch, dass das TÜV hat. Und wenn das TÜV hat, sind nämlich zwei Sachen passiert. Das haben sich Leute angeguckt und ich weiß, dass sich das Leute angeguckt haben. Wenn das nicht passiert ist, dann sorge ich dafür, dass sich das jemand anguckt.
Das hat aber auch echt eine Weile gedauert. Wenn du dir anguckst, wo der TÜV herkommt, das ist der Dampfkessel- Nein, das ist doch jetzt nur ein- Nein, Marcus, hör zu. Das ist der Dampfkessel-Überprüfungsverein. Ursprünglich gewesen, der nicht wollte, dass die Dampfkessel, wo die Ingenieure dran basteln, immer um die Ohren fliegen. Da sind echt viele Ingenieure bei draufgegangen. Und es hat einfach mal 50 Jahre gedauert, wie sie an Dampfkesseln gebastelt haben, bis dann irgendwann mal gesagt haben, okay, ist jetzt schlimm genug, jetzt braucht es eine Instanz, die das überprüfen kann, wo genug Experten drin sind. Die erstens Ahnung davon haben und zweitens das auch überprüfen wollen und dann wir auch als Dienstleistung anbieten. Das heißt, die relativ neue Technologie, die da mit dieser Software gerade bedeutend wird, die hat da noch nicht genug Zeit gehabt, so abgehangen zu werden, dass die da alle Erfahrungen haben und wissen, wie wir damit hingehen müssen.
Dann nehme ich gleich noch was dazu zu sagen. Aber worauf ich hinaus wollte, ist ja dieses, okay, da sind halt 50 Ingenieure in einem Dampfkessel explodiert. Es tut mir leid, um Ingenieure, aber es sind halt nur 50. Diese Open-SSL-Software wird halt von Millionen von Leuten benutzt. Und auch große Firmen benutzen die. Okay, 20 Jahre, wenn ich nicht schreibe, aber gut. Du hast halt immer diesen Multiplikator bei Software, weil Software, die breit eingesetzt wird, wird breit eingesetzt. Das heißt, jeden Incident, den du hast, der wird natürlich x-fach multipliziert. Das ist klar. Und genau deswegen ist ja meine Frage, warum hat sich die... Also das Argument von der Open Source Software ist. Das Argument von der Open Source Software ist, die ist Open Source und damit ist sie sicherer, denn sie kann sich von vielen Leuten angeguckt werden. Warum macht das niemand? Und das ist auch in der Tat passiert. Das ist ja nicht so, als ob jetzt niemand da drauf geguckt hätte. Es gibt nur zwei Dinge, die es schwierig machen. Nummer eins, du weißt nicht unbedingt, wer sich das angeguckt hat. Du weißt nur, dass sich das angeguckt wurde. Weil diese Bibliothek, jetzt muss ich noch mal gerade einen Begriff einführen, war FIBS-zertifiziert. Sie war was? FIBS-zertifiziert. Das ist ein federal... Irgendwas processing standard.
Es ist ein Stempel von der US-amerikanischen Regierung.
Total vertrauenswürdig. Nicht von der Regierung, sondern vor allen Dingen im Auftrag. Also es ist ein Stempel einer Institution, der du echt viel Geld überwiesen hast.
Also richtig viel Geld.
Wir reden hier so 50k plus. Dass sie dir bestätigt, dass sie das, was die US-Regierung gerne hätte, erfüllt, deine Bibliothek.
Viele andere haben dann gesagt, na gut, wenn es für die US-amerikanische Regierung gut genug ist, dann ist es für uns auch gut genug.
Entschuldigt mal, liebe Leute vom CCC, handläufig auch Nerds genannt. Seit wann ist es so, wenn eine Regierungsstelle oder eine von der Regierung beaufragte Stelle kommt und sagt, ja, wir haben mal nachgeguckt, wie die Regierung quasi, Konkursativ sozusagen, haben mal nachgeguckt und haben gesagt, wir überwachen euch auch nicht, Ehrenwort, und wir haben gesagt, diese Software ist total sicher. Seit wann ist das für euch gut genug?
Es ist ja nicht für uns gut genug. Das Ding ist nur, dass es deswegen von anderen Leuten benutzt worden ist, die dann schon gedacht haben, oh, da ist ein Stempel von der, du fragst ja jetzt in die Runde, warum sie es niemand angeguckt haben. Was du aber eigentlich fragen möchtest, sag mal, warum hast denn du da nicht reingeguckt, Erdgeist? So, willst du mich das fragen?
Ja bitte, Erdgeist, warum hast du das nicht, also du weißt, also nee, nee, warte, ich muss fairerweise das andere fragen. Hättest du die technische Kompetenz, um dir diesen Programmcode anzugucken? Warum hast du es nicht gemacht?
Hab ich.
Warum ist dir der Fehler nicht aufgefallen?
In dem speziellen Fall ist die Programmierbibliothek, weil sie als Hobbyistenprojekt entstanden ist ursprünglich und dann von diversen anderen Leuten frankensteinmäßig ausgefranst. Die war die Komplexität der Software und die Programmierschnittstellen, die man braucht, um diese Bibliothek zu benutzen. Und dann die Pfade von, wo man in diese Bibliothek reinspringt, bis dann am Ende, wo wirklich das Silikon, die kommandos aushöht, war einfach so verschachtelt, so durch mehrere Abstraktions-Ebenen versteckt, was die Software wirklich tut, dass man als Programmierer, der da reinguckt und sich nicht wirklich mal einen Monat Zeit genommen hat, und zwar einen Monat Vollzeit Zeit genommen hat, das komplett auseinanderzunehmen, war es nicht realistisch schaffbar. Also ich hätte mir einen Monat Zeit nehmen müssen, um vollständig da mal erstmal so einen architekturellen Überblick zu bekommen und dann alle wichtigen Code-Pfade da drin zu überprüfen. Und ich habe da ein paar Mal versucht reinzugucken und habe es dann wie schnell wieder zugeklappt, weil es einfach nicht realistisch war.
Okay, ich lasse es einfach mal so stehen. Florian, du musst jetzt alle drei diese Frage machen. Florian, wärst du technisch in der Lage, diese Programmbibliothek zu untersuchen?
Ich wäre technisch in der Lage, das zu untersuchen, mir anzugucken und vielleicht auch den Code zu verstehen, was er tut. Das Problem ist, man muss den Kontext von jeder Zeile kennen. Und es ist ja auch nicht so, dass man einmal einen Aufruf macht, mach mir jetzt eine sichere Verbindung, sondern lass ihn dann so 20. Und dann gibt es da 100 Fehlerfälle, die auftreten können, mit denen man umgehen muss.
Naja klar, ich hab dir nicht gesagt, dass es einfach ist, aber man kann den Code schon überprüfen. Warum hast du es nicht gemacht?
Weil ich dachte, das ist sicher und da gucken ja auch bestimmt andere drauf.
Okay, also ich will jetzt niemand beschärmen oder so. Es geht ja genau darum aufzuzeigen, warum das passiert ist, was passiert ist.
Ich kann nicht auf alle Software, also alle Software, die ich benutze, kann ich mir nicht im Detail angucken. Dazu lebe ich nicht lang genug. Das heißt, ich muss natürlich immer anderen Menschen vertrauen und diese Annahme auch trauen.
Okay, Danimo, könntest du das? Vermutlich, ich würde es mir nur nicht zutrauen, weil es, wie gesagt, echt komplex ist. Das heißt, es ist für dich eine Zeitfrage oder ist es tatsächlich eine Verständnisfrage? Sowohl als auch. Also ich bin kein ausgewiesener Kryptograph. Ich bin kein ausgewiesener Sicherheitsmensch. Und das heißt, ich nähere mich diesem Thema jetzt also seit Heartbleed speziell ein bisschen. Aber deswegen, ich hätte halt nie gesagt, wenn ich jetzt hier meinen Stempel drauf packe, dann ist das deswegen sicher. Weil ich gar nicht sagen könnte, dass ich diesen Stempel überhaupt ausstellen könnte. Okay, aber du hättest ja wenigstens für dich sozusagen persönlich überprüfen können. Nee, also ich hab mir zum Beispiel auch diesen Heartbleed Patch angeguckt. Also dieses Stück Code Differenz, die quasi zeigt, wo der Fehler lag. Und zwei interessante Sachen sind da. A, werden da Werte wild aufeinander addiert. Also wirklich, da stehen wirklich Zahlen. Und du musst halt wissen, warum diese Zahlen aus irgendeinem Grund da jetzt drauf addiert wurden. Und zweitens hast du Software, also wenn du sowas analysierst, die nennt sich Statische Code Analyzer. Und das klingt jetzt kompliziert, ist aber letztendlich nichts anderes als ein Programm, das durchgeht und aufgrund gewisser Regelwerke, die irgendjemand da mal rein programmiert hat und gewisse Annahmen, die man sehr wahrscheinlich treffen kann, halt sagt, das ist kaputt, das ist kaputt, guck dir das mal bitte nochmal an. Du kriegst halt so einen schönen übersichtlichen Report. Und alle Software, die das tut, auch im kommerziellen Umfeld, hat diesen Bug nicht gefunden. Das heißt, du kannst davon ausgehen, dass Leute diese Software da drauf gelassen haben, aber weil dieser Code so verschachtelt, hässlich und unglaublich furchtbar ist, haben sie es tatsächlich geschafft, selbst Static Code Analyzers auszutricksen. Also in Anführungszeichen auszutricksen. Ok, nächste Frage. Ihr alle würdet sagen, das ist schon eine wichtige Bibliothek, diese OpenSSL. Ihr alle würdet sagen, das wäre schon gut, wenn sich das mal jemand angeguckt hätte. Ihr alle habt es selber nicht gemacht, aus Gründen. Wie ist es denn jetzt, zum Beispiel der CCC ist ja nun eine Vereinigung, die besteht aus mehr als euch drei Leuten, oder? Ist mir zu ordnen gekommen. Man hätte sich jetzt zum Beispiel hinsetzen können und sagen können, hier, wir finanzieren, nein. Oder wir setzen uns mal zusammen und machen das irgendwie. Es gibt dieses schöne Ding, Verantwortungsthiffusion heißt das, glaube ich. Also je mehr Leute theoretisch für ein Event, das verantwortlich sind, desto weniger kümmern sich darum. Ist das das, was da passiert? Also dass alle wie ihr davor sitzen und denken, also man müsste eigentlich mal, aber es wird schon jemand. Das ist diese Autounfallgeschichte, die du meinst, wenn du an einem Autounfall vorbei fährst und hinter dir ist einer, dann sagst du ja, kann der auch machen. Und ich denke so, ja, es läuft auch so ein bisschen darauf hinaus, gerade wenn du halt nicht ausgewiesen in der Branche arbeitest, also Security irgendwie deine Profession ist oder zumindest deine Leidenschaft ist.
Na, es gibt eine Geschichte von Großprojekten, wo jemand hingegangen ist und gesagt hat, wir müssten mal Software bauen, die uns toll kollekt, die uns die LKW-Maut einspielt. Und dann wurde das von den üblichen Verdächtigen, die bei so Ausschreibungen immer ganz vorne mit dabei sind, genau alle Spezifikationen der Ausschreibung zu erfüllen, aber am Ende vielleicht eher so, nur minderbegabte Programmierer am Start haben, wird es dann implementiert. Das heißt, wenn der CCC sich hinstellt und sagt, wir wedeln mal mit ganz viel Geld, braucht es dann am Ende auch wieder Projektmanagement. Es braucht irgendjemanden, der bestimmen kann, wohin soll das Geld gehen, nach welchen Auswahlkriterien wollen wir die Leute bestimmen. Es ist nicht so einfach. Es ist ziemlich viel Sozialdynamik, die am Ende dazu führt, dass man auch dafür sorgen muss, dass die Mittel ordentlich verwendet werden. Ich weiß nicht, ob das so im Scope vom CCC gerade ist, das genau das zu leisten.
Ja, aber ihr habt doch vorhin bei TrueCrypt zum Beispiel erzählt, dass genau das passiert ist. Dass sich da jemand herangesetzt hat und gesagt hat, ich gucke jetzt diese Software mal an. Wie ist das denn gelaufen?
Es gibt immer, also auch der Heartbleed Bug wurde gefunden, als sich Google ein paar Engineers, die sie für schlau gehalten haben, genommen hat und für eine Weile bezahlt hat. Und auch da sind sie dann über den Fehler gestolpert und haben den dann öffentlich gemacht. Ich glaube auch noch jemand anderes, der den unabhängig davon gefunden hat. Aber zumindest sind es gerade Organisationen, die davon leben, dass das Internet einigermaßen sicher ist und dass die Informationen halt nur bei ihnen landen und nicht bei irgendjemandem anders. Deswegen hat Google gesagt, wenn alle auf OpenSSL vertrauen, dann gucken wir da auch mal rein. Ich denke aber, dass es, wenn es ein so wichtiges Teil der kritischen Infrastruktur ist, die das Netz betreibt, dann sollte eigentlich eher der Staat mal dahergehen und sagen, wir haben sowas wie das BSI. Das ist genau dafür da, für die Sicherheit der Informationstechnologie zu sorgen. Die sollten dann mal hergehen und sagen, nach Best Practices in der Industrie gucken wir dann mal drauf.
Okay, also, dann fasse ich mal das Ergebnis der letzten halben Stunde und ihr könnt nachher widersprechen. Ich erfasse das jetzt nur als kleines Ding zusammen. Die Idee vor diesem Open Source macht das Ganze irgendwie sicherer. Ist eigentlich, wenn wir es mal zusammenfassen, Quatsch. Ob das stimmt oder nicht, klämmer gleich. Ihr seid im Chaosradio im Blue Moon. Es ist genau 23 Uhr und hier sind die Nerd News mit Scarlett Kuboschek.
Bundesanwaltschaft will nicht in Geheimdiensterfähre ermitteln. Generalbundesanwalt Range wird nach Berichten der Süddeutschen Zeitung nicht wegen des Verdachts auf Spionage ermitteln. Der CCC und die humanistische Union hatten Strafanzeige gestellt. Snowden selbst bestritt, je von offizieller Stelle wegen Unterlagen kontaktiert worden zu sein. Die Opposition bezeichnete das Nichtermitteln als beispiellosen Akt der Rechtsbeugung. iPhone als Geisel genommen. Unbekannte haben die Apple IDs etlicher iPhone-Benutzer in Australien und Neuseeland übernommen. Über die eingebaute Find-My-iPhone-Funktion sperrten sie die iPhones der Besitzer und stellten eine Lösegeldforderung. Die Unbekannten drohen darin mit dem Löschen des iPhones, falls der Besitzer der Forderung nicht nachkommt. Apple gab in einer Stellungnahme bekannt, dass der Clouddienst selbst nicht gehackt worden sei. BSI warnt vor gehackten FTP-Servern. Das Bundesamt für Sicherheit in der Informationstechnik hat bei der Analyse eines sogenannten Botnetzes 200.000 Passwörter zu FTP-Servern gefunden. Diese werden vermutlich verwendet, um auf den dazugehörigen Web-Servern Schadsoftware abzulegen. Die so infizierten Webseiten nutzen Sicherheitslücken von Browsern aus, um die Rechner nichts an der Nutzer zu infizieren. Die betroffenen Administratoren sollen nun von ihren Hosting-Providern informiert werden.
Die Nord News mit Scarlett Kubosdick. Danke.
H-h-
Im Chaosradio in Blue Moon, das war Professor Click mit This und Professor Click ist einer der genialsten Creative Commons Musiker und der ist gerade in Deutschland. Ihr müsst zwar bis nach Bayreuth fahren, wenn ihr meine 30. Mai erleben wollt, aber er ist in Deutschland. Das ist sehr selten. Tut es euch an, wenn ihr könnt. So zurück zum Chaosradio hier in Blue Moon. Es geht um Sicherheit, um Computersicherheit. Wir haben eine Stunde lang damit zugebracht, erst mal zu klären, was für grandiose, großartige Fehlschläge es gibt im Bereich der Open-Source-Software. Mit dabei sind Erdgeist, Florian und Danimo. Und wir haben dann auch versucht zu klären, die Idee hinter Open-Source ist ja, dass theoretisch jeder reingucken kann in die Software und den Fehler auch finden kann. Und wir haben von euch jetzt ganz persönlich gehört, das ist halt nicht so einfach, weil diese Software super kompliziert ist. Und man braucht zum Beispiel, Erdgeist meint das, man müsste sich einen ganzen Monat reinhängen. Der hat man natürlich nicht immer, aber hat man auch einfach keinen Bock dazu. Wir haben auch gelernt, dass bei dieser Open Source Software, wo theoretisch alle reingucken können, dass die Beispiel, die wir jetzt gehört haben, immer nur passiert ist, weil große Firmen da Geld drauf geworfen haben auf das Problem. Da könnte man sagen, naja gut, also ich meine, Open Source ist praktisch, weil die Firma kann dann den Quellcode lesen, damit könnte sie sich vielleicht auch kaufen. Aber im Prinzip diese Idee, dass da jeder reingucken kann, die hat uns bis jetzt, also zumindest heute in der Sendung, nicht wirklich geholfen. Jetzt vermute ich, dass wir gerade über die extremen Ausfälle – nee, andersrum – ich hoffe, dass wir gerade über die extremen Ausfälle sprechen und dass dieses Konzept Open Source möglicherweise doch funktioniert. Ich würde von euch jetzt gerne wissen, wie ist das denn jetzt, wenn jemand Programmiercode geschrieben hat und möchte, dass der kontrolliert wird? Wie läuft das denn ab? Gibt es da wirklich, gibt es da sozusagen schon Strukturen, die geschaffen wurden, gibt es da bestimmte Vorgehensweise? Wie kriegt man so jemand? Und ich würde, ich möchte an dieser Stelle auch aufrufen, ihr könnt gerne anrufen, wenn ihr selber eine von den folgenden Dingen gemacht habt, ihr seid Programmierer und habt einen wirklich schlimmen Super-Go erlebt mit eurer Software, seid auf die Nase gefallen, weil ihr eine schlimme Sicherheitslücke hattet, oder ihr habt mal eine Software kontrolliert und habt einen wirklich schlimmen Fehler gefunden und könnt vielleicht davon erzählen, wie schwierig es war, dann die entsprechenden, die entsprechenden Programmierer darauf hinzuweisen oder sowas. 0331 70 97 120, falls ihr eine schöne Anekdote aus dem Bereich Sicherheitslücken in Open Source Software erzählen könnt. Dann die Mo. Sicherheit in Open Source, du hast gerade deine Hand gehoben, deswegen bist du jetzt dran. Wunderschön. Also bei Open Source, es ist ja nicht der große Open Source-Brei, in dem irgendwo Dinge entstehen, sondern du hast ja ganz häufig Projekte, um die sich das Ganze dreht. Im einfachsten Fall bedeutet das, dass du dein eigenes Projekt bist, weil du dein eigenes Ding drehst, du hast Software gemacht und du bestehst erstmal völlig alleine da. Und das machst du ja Open Source mit einem gewissen Ziel. Und eines dieser Ziele ist halt auch Mixstreiter zu bekommen. Und was man dann halt machen kann, ist man kann es auf so Seiten wie GitHub stellen. Das ist also eine Seite, die genau dafür gemacht ist, quasi in der Öffentlichkeit zu entwickeln. Und dort gibt es eingebaute Funktionalitäten für Review. Und dein größtes Problem ist dann nicht, dieses Review zu machen, sondern dein größtes Problem ist erst mal jemanden zu finden, der das tatsächlich für dich tut. Also quasi dieselben Interessen hat, die du auch verfolgst eben. Oder diese Bibliothek verwenden will und sie vorher angucken will oder sich sogar aktiv beteiligen möchte. Und dann sagt, okay, pass auf, ich deine Änderung, du meine Änderung. Und wir schauen dann da quasi drüber. Der etwas einfachere Fall für den Review ist, du beteiligst dich an einem bestehenden Projekt. Die haben normalerweise eine Vorgehensweise, wie sie neue Patches, so nennt sich das, wenn man Code beiträgt, anschauen, unter welchen Kriterien sie dir durchlassen. Das ist je nach Projekt mal mehr, mal weniger formell. Also das gibt einfach Projekte, die dir einfach ganz schnell Vertrauen schenken. Und es gibt Projekte, wo du echt lange irgendwie so ne Art Anwärterschaft machen musst. Und dann wird halt ganz besonders gut auf deinen Code draufgeguckt. Und irgendwann sieht man, okay, der weiß, was er tut, die Codequalität ist in Ordnung. Und dann wird vielleicht nicht mehr, entweder wahlweise wird, das schleift sich halt ein, dass möglicherweise nicht mehr ganz so stark draufgeguckt wird. Das hängt halt sehr stark von der Disziplin ab. Aber vor allen Dingen du kriegst... Das ist aber eigentlich Quatsch, ne? Das ist das, was du eigentlich nicht willst. Du willst eigentlich, dass...
Da gibt es eine ganz lustige Anekdote, dass dieser Heartbleed Bug, der wurde ja dann ganz schnell von mehreren großen Projekten, die diese Open-SSL-Bibliothek mit ausliefern. Na ja, nicht gefixt, aber erst mal wurde dieses Feature, dieser Programmteil ausgeschaltet und die Bibliotheken nochmal neu zusammengerollt und mit ausgeliefert. Und eines der Projekte, das OpenBSD Projekt, was sich jetzt auch auf die Fahnen geschrieben hat, dieses Open-SSL-Projekt heile zu machen, die haben dann gleich ganz panisch drauf reagiert, haben dann in die Zeile in dem einen Pfeil, was dafür sorgt, dass es gebaut wird, gesagt, dann mach mal dieses Feature bitte nicht und haben dann Rechtschreibfehler eingebaut. Also sie haben irgendwie den S hinten vergessen und deswegen wurde das Feature trotzdem noch mitgebaut. Und zwei Leute aus dem Projekt haben da draufgeguckt, haben gesagt, ja, ist in Ordnung, haben es abgewunken, weil der Typ der Theodorat, der das da eingecheckt hat, der weiß schon, was er tut, der macht das üblicherweise richtig und ist dann ironischerweise auch, obwohl zwei Leute da in diesem Open Source Projekt, OpenBSD, draufgeguckt haben, ist dann dieser Flüchtigkeitsfehler da auch durchgeflutscht. Also die Art und Weise, nicht selber noch mal zu überprüfen, ob man gerade alles richtig gemacht hat und das dann als Rage-Commit, also als noch erschaffiertes, erschaffierte Art, DOS-Software zu committen, ist irgendwie so ein Stack. Das sind halt Menschen und die machen Fehler. Und wenn nicht andere Leute da irgendwie noch mal wirklich ihrer Aufgabe nachkommen, den Fehlern anderer Leuten hinterher zu gucken, dann schleift sich das ein und dann kommt der Fehler da auch rein.
Aber das ist ganz interessant, weil du kommst sozusagen schon an dieser Stelle da rein, das Open-Source-Software halt immer auch sozusagen sozialpsychologisch ist. Weil man könnte dir sagen, da macht man es so wie bei den Wissenschaftlern, also peer review, nämlich du kriegst den Code zwar vorgelegt, aber du weißt nicht, von wem er ist. Dann musst du ja richtig gucken.
Das ist das eine, aber das andere ist, dass es nur Menschen drauf gucken zu lassen, ist mir eigentlich auch zu wenig. In allen Projekten, die man heutzutage anfängt, würde ich sagen, das automatisierte Code Review, statische Code Analyse, vielleicht noch ein sogenanntes Linting, also ein Programm, das automatisch dafür sorgt, dass der Programmiercode immer gleich formatiert ist, dass Leute, die da ein Leerzeichen vor der Klammer, eins nach der Klammer machen, die nur Einrückungen nehmen, dass das alles soweit normalisiert wird, dass jeder ganz genau weiß, was ihn erwartet, wenn er dieses Stück Programmcode sich auf sein Rechner runterlädt, dann sieht es halt immer so aus, dass er nicht erst noch die Lieblingseinrückungsgewohnheiten des Programmierers dort lernen muss, sondern gleich raufguckt und das sieht.
Und da sind wir bei Go To Fail wieder, weil das war ja genau das Problem. Es wurden Konventionen angewandt, die man halt so oder so machen kann. Da wurden sie halt so gemacht und dann haben ganz viele Leute das Problem möglicherweise deswegen übersehen, weil sie es möglicherweise anders gewohnt sind. Und wir waren ja vorhin schon bei den Punkten da, weil du gerade sagst, man braucht auch diese automatische Code-Analyse, aber wir haben ja bei... war es bei Go To Fail? Oder war es bei Heartbleed? Da haben wir gelernt, da hat genau das nicht funktioniert. Also du brauchst schon Menschen.
Auch klar. Bloß es ist ein mehrstufiges Modell und du musst erstmal schon so viel Anspruch an dich selber haben, dass du bei jedem Commit, also jedes Mal wenn du neue Funktionalitäten in dein Projekt hinzugeben willst, dass du, bevor du es in die Öffentlichkeit entlässt, dass du es mindestens einmal bei dir testest, ob es überhaupt ein funktionierendes Binary erzeugt. So das passiert bei vielen Leuten nicht. Das gibt irgendwie inzwischen, haben sich Best Practices, also so ein paar Standards herausgebildet, wie man seine Software schreibt, dass man bestimmte Fehler vermeidet. Es gibt irgendwie so Test Driven Development. Das heißt du schreibst zuallererst einigermaßen formal auf, wie du glaubst, dass sich dein Stück Software verhalten soll. Das sind meistens so viele kleinere Units, die dann sagen, das soll eine Addition machen. Dann schreibst du halt so Tests. Ich will gucken, dass wenn der was addiert, dass dann noch die Summe rauskommt. Dann gebe ich irgendwie noch ein paar Werte rein, wo, keine Ahnung, bei der Division zum Beispiel, soll der einen Fehler zurückgebern, wenn man durch Null dividiert. Ich schreibe zuerst meinen Test und schreibe danach die Funktion, die diesen Test erfüllen muss, sodass ich immer sicher bin, dass wenn ich irgendwann mal später betrunken an dieser Funktion irgendwas mache, weil ich glaube, ich habe eine tolle Idee, wie die tausendmal schneller ist. Und dann funktioniert der Test plötzlich nicht mehr. Dann weiß ich, okay, da war vielleicht eine blöde Idee, dann kommt das nicht.
Also das geht schon wieder sehr weit und es geht auch sehr weit in die Automatisierung.
Das ist sehr sozial. Das ist ja schon, dass man sich hinsetzt und sagt, ich möchte nicht einfach nur, ich bin schon schlau genug, dass wenn ich meine Software so runterschreibe, dass die dann schon stimmt, sondern dass sie mindestens noch von halbautomatischen oder vollautomatischen Werkzeugen überprüft wird.
Und es zwingt dich zu zwei Dingen. Zum einen zwingt es dich, sehr kleinteilig zu programmieren. Weil nämlich diese Tests, die du schreibst, die kannst du ja nur, wenn du jetzt anfängst, irgendwie eine riesen Funktion, die ganz viel kann und ganz viel soll. Ja, und dann schreib mal da für Tests. Da wirst du nämlich wahnsinnig. Okay, also du zwingst dich auf zu einem sauberen Code-Stil. Weißt du gerade, warum ich meine, warum man abweichnet? Wir sind jetzt beim Programmierer selber. Und es geht ja um dieses Open Source-Ding. Also du hast den Code, dann guckt jemand anders rein. Also eine Sache, die mir jetzt gerade aufgefallen ist, was sie erzählt hat, ist, dass bei den funktionierenden Systemen sich zum Beispiel Leute absprechen, also du guckst meine Neuerung an, ich gucke deine Neuerung an. Dann wird also immer nur kontrolliert, was neu dazukommt. Und jetzt ist ja Software, wird ja irgendwie riesig lang, riesig komplex. Reicht das, wenn man immer nur diese einzelnen Codeschnipsel anguckt? Oder müsste man nicht einfach so, keine Ahnung, alle zwei Monate sagen, so jetzt noch einmal das ganze Ding?
Ja, das gibt irgendwie so noch ein inhärentes Problem. Das üblicherweise ist Software, sagt man so pro 100.000 Zeilen, irgendwie so was wie zehn Fehler und wenn man sich jetzt hinsetzt und irgendwo aus Projekten größere Mengen Code entsorgt, hat man nirgends wo, wo man seinen Namen ranschreiben kann. Also wenn man neue Features reinbaut, kann man ganz stolz oben ranschreiben, mal geschrieben und dann weiß jeder, der hat sich daran beteiligt. Wenn man irgendwie aus einem großen Projekt viel rausschneidet, dann steht da üblicherweise der Name nicht dran. Das heißt, man ist nicht besonders der strahlende Held, der eine neues Feature, wo alle was dann auch sehen können, dass da jemand in der Software was getan hat. So, denk irgendwie Fußstapfen im Zement. So, hier, da, das war ich. Und deswegen setzen sich Programmierer, die an so Open-Source-Projekten sich beteiligen. Die brauchen eine Motivation, warum sie das tun. Es gibt klar, wenn du im Firmenumfeld arbeitest, dann winkt da jemand mit mehr oder weniger großen Mengen Geld und sagt, hier, mach mal. Und der kann auch sagen, hier, mach mal ein Code-Review, mach mal auditierbar mal die Software. Das heißt, schauen, ob da Fehler drin sind.
Das Problem mit diesem Open-Source-Ding ist also auch, dass den Code nochmal anzugucken, zwar eigentlich sehr wichtig ist, aber einer der Sachen ist, die am wenigsten Spaß macht. Also die a, anstrengend ist und b, wenig Fame gibt.
Das siehst du in Open-Source-Software ziemlich häufig, dass es da erst ganz langsam eine Entwicklung gibt, dass so eine Kultur von, da haben Leute gerade vorgelegt, haben das, was sie normalerweise für Geld machen, nämlich programmieren und Software schreiben, haben sie in die Öffentlichkeit entlassen, um ein tolles Tool zu schreiben, was jeder benutzen kann. Und zwar für umsonst. Früher hast du das immer gesehen, dass man mit Open Office zum Beispiel nicht mit MS Word mithalten konnte, weil in MS Word einfach viel Zeit und Energie von Leuten drin gesteckt hat, die üblicherweise nicht nur programmieren, sondern Leute, die große Worttrennungstabellen geschrieben haben, Leute, die Vorlagen designt haben, die man im Büro brauchen kann, die Integration an SAP-Systeme gebastelt haben, die einfach keinen Spaß machen. Es gibt immer Leute, die auf den lustigsten Dingen Spaß beziehen. Aber ein Programmierer hat an sowas üblicherweise nicht Freude und dann wird das halt nicht gemacht. Und die Dynamik, dass jemand sieht, Open-Source-Software ist, was total toll ist, wo man sich dran beteiligen kann, auch wenn man kein Programmierer ist. Nämlich als Grafiker, was ich auch gerne gesehen habe, dass Open-Source-Projekte nicht so schön aussehen, weil wie lange sich dann...
Ich denn das liebevolle Open-Source-Style, wenn das hässlich ist.
Genau, dass also auch Gestalter, die natürlich dahergekommen sind und gesagt haben, ich verdiene ja Geld damit. Warum soll ich jetzt so ein Open-Source-Projekt was schenken? Da braucht es auch eine Weile, bis jetzt viele Gestalter verstanden haben, dass sie dort dem guten Beispiel der Programmierer dort mal folgen. Aber da gibt es halt auch noch Fame, ne? Natürlich gibt es irgendwie auch Open-Source-Programmierer wollen Fame.
Ja, die können auch die Frage sagen. Also diese Reviews, also dieses noch mal angucken, da kannst du halt auch nicht deinen Namen dran schreiben und sagen, so hier, ich hab jetzt das jetzt angeguckt.
Ich hab's ja selber erlebt. Ich habe ja ein Stück Software geschrieben, heißt OpenTracker, wird benutzt bei The Pirate Bay in echt riesengroßem Stil. Und bevor die Software dort eingesetzt worden ist, hab ich mir auch in die Hosen gemacht. Das ist so die prominente Software, die mehrere Zehntausend Requests pro Sekunde bearbeitet. Natürlich gibt es da irgendjemanden, der dann mal einfach nur ums Pirate Bay zu zeigen, dort dann Fehler in der Software sucht und dann bin ich rumgegangen, hab bei allen gefragt, ob sie nicht mal kurz auf wenigstens die kritischen Routinen in meinem Po draufgucken wollen und hab dann überall Kopfschütteln geerntet, weil es halt, naja, kostet halt Zeit und hätte normalerweise Geld gekostet. Und die paar Leute, die dann die Zeit erübrigt haben, waren dann üblicherweise auch die, die nur als Praktikanten in den Security Firmen gearbeitet haben und dann nicht ihre ganze Expertise drauf werfen konnten.
Das ist echt so Security Review, das kleine ungeliebte Kind. Na ja, ich bin gespannt. Wir können über die Zukunft davon gleich noch reden. Florian, hast du auch schon Erfahrungen gesammelt? Also selber jetzt persönlich mit, wie das überhaupt funktioniert mit diesem Review? Oder hast du vielleicht selber sogar schon mal was reviewt?
Ich kam irgendwann mal in die etwas unglückliche Lage, mir PHP bringen zu müssen, um eine Software zu reviewen im Firmenumfeld. Und das war kein Spaß.
Ich überlege gerade, will man jetzt mal sagen, jemand, der nichts über Projekte weiß, erklären kann, was PHP ist. PHP hat ungefähr den Ruf von, stellt euch vor, Sinja aus Marzahn macht zusammen mit Heino einen Song und ihr solltet die theoretische Musikanalyse dafür schreiben. Ich glaube, das trifft das ungefähr.
Ich glaube, das ist gar nicht mal so schlimm, weil die folgt gewissen Formalien. PHP ist eine Sprache, die hat halt, ich dachte, die hat Seiteneffekte. Ich habe später gelernt, dass die Seiteneffekte das Konzept dieser Sprache sind. Und im kommerziellen Umfeld hat man halt häufig das Problem, es ist nicht nur so, dass da Leute nicht draufgucken, weil sie keine Lust dazu haben, sondern ich müsste ja wirklich Geld dafür in die Hand nehmen. Und wenn ich dann die Abwägung mache, naja, a, kostet es Geld, jemanden draufgucken zu lassen, naja, hm, ist das das eine. Dann kostet es auch noch Geld, die Fehler, die der findet, zuzufixen und zuzumachen. Und dann mache ich die Abwägung, naja, wenn mir jetzt jemand meinen Webshop aufmacht, dann bin ich dagegen versichert und habe maximal diesen und jeden Ausfall. Es ist vielleicht billiger, den Bug einfach drin zu lassen, weil es ist eh unwahrscheinlich, dass jemand ihn findet. Und es ist halt nicht nur so, dass jemand die Software nicht nur angucken kann, weil sie nicht Open Source ist. Selbst wenn da Fehler bekannt sind, heißt es nicht, dass sie gefixt werden, weil die kosten Geld und dann muss man die Software wieder neu ausrollen und an die Kunden verteilen und denen erklären, warum man eigentlich so schlecht ist, mit diesem Software entwickeln und dauernd wieder neue Versionen rausbringen muss und dauernd erklären muss, warum da wieder Fehler drin waren. So dass das auch in dem Umfeld jetzt nicht wirklich voll befriedigend ist, auch wenn da das Geld da wäre, um Reviews zu machen.
Also je mehr ich darüber höre, desto verwundlicher finde ich, dass es überhaupt schon mal als Software angeguckt wurde. Dannimo, wie ist es bei dir? Hast du auch schon so Erfahrungen gesammelt? Das klingt jetzt anruhig.
Das ist wie auf der Bravo, rosa Seiten einmal.
Also ich arbeite beim QT Projekt mit unter anderem. Erklär mal kurz, was das ist für Leute, die das wissen. Das wäre jetzt mal ein nächstes. Ja und zwar ist das eine Bibliothek, mit der man letztendlich sehr einfach für verschiedene Plattformen Programme schreiben muss. Normalerweise musst du ja irgendwie für Linux was schreiben, für Mac was schreiben, für Windows was schreiben, für irgendwelche Embedded-Geräte was schreiben, für deine Handys was schreiben musst. Jedes Mal quasi eine andere Software dafür hernehmen und QT ermöglicht dir das halt alles mehr oder weniger über einen Kamm zu scheren. Das ist quasi wie eine Bibliothek, die Verschüsselung ermöglicht, nur für etwas anderes.
Grob gesagt.
Ich kann dir nur unbedingt folgen, Entschuldigung. Aber es ist einfach wie eine SSL Bibliothek, du willst eigentlich nur dein Problem lösen und das Problem auf liebe Plattform, liebes Windows, liebes Mac OS, mach das doch mal für mich oder zeichne für mich dieses Fenster, das nimmt dir das QT ab. Ich kann in meiner Software dann sagen, Software, zeichne einen Kreis. Oder mal mir ein Fenster, mal mir einen Button. Okay, also mach Effekte und dann die Software übersetzt das automatisch für das jeweilige Betriebssystem, wie es dort genau funktioniert. Genau und das sehr unschöne ist, du musst das natürlich auch für, und da sind wir wieder beim Thema, SSL leisten. Also du hast da natürlich eine Browser Komponente, du möchtest ja auch gerne Netzwerkverkehr machen, du möchtest gerne in der Lage sein, mit Verschlüsseln mit Servern zu reden. Also ist dort auch eine OpenSSL-Integration mit drin und auch das muss irgendwie getestet werden, auch das muss irgendwie sichergestellt werden, dass es das tut, was es soll. Also du kannst ja mit OpenSSL noch schlimme Dinge tun. Ich hatte jetzt den Vorteil, es war schon vieles da und ich habe eigentlich nur noch Fehler gefunden, die ich da drin beheben wollte. Und was ich da getan habe, ist ich habe mir erst mal angeguckt, ist dieses Problem in meinem Programm? Nein, da war es nicht. Ist das Problem in QT? Ja, ist es. Aber ist es vielleicht auch in OpenSSL? Dann habe ich festgestellt Mist, es ist in OpenSSL. Und dann habe ich mir OpenSSL angeguckt und dann ist genau das passiert, was Erdgäst gesagt hat. Ich habe ganz schnell wieder zugemacht und habe beschlossen, das Ganze ein Layer drüber zu beheben. Also quasi in QT, was in dem Fall tatsächlich auch ein valider Ansatz war. Naja, aber das Problem ist, du siehst schon, man versucht es gar nicht. Ja, aber genau, du hast einen Fehler gefunden, der ja alle betrifft. Genau. Du hast ihn für dich repariert. Nein, also für das Projekt, nachdem ich festgestellt habe, dass jeder andere, was offensichtlich nur bei ganz wenigen der Fall war, aber jeder andere, der das gemacht hat, hat auch einen Workaround, um das eigentliche Problem gemacht, um bloß nichts in OpenSSL zu machen. Also wisst ihr, diese Sendung dauert jetzt eineinhalb Stunden. Ich bin jetzt an dem Punkt angekommen, wo ich mich wundere, warum das Internet noch nicht explodiert ist. Also ich meine, ist es ja quasi. Okay, so wir haben jetzt natürlich einen Anrufer. Martin, ist 29, kommt aus Wien und hat eine Frage. Hallo Martin.
Hallo, ich bin Mathematiker und höre ganz gespannt zu und interessiert das Problem, das ich habe. Ich kann halt ein bisschen programmieren. Also ich arbeite mittlerweile als Programmierer. Aber ich habe eigentlich auch nicht die nötigen Ressourcen, dass ich mir irgendwie, keine Ahnung, jetzt so gut C anlerne, dass ich Open SSL lernen kann. Wo gibt es da Ressourcen oder wo kann ich einsteigen, dass ich an meinen kleineren Projekten mitarbeite oder dass ich Krypto so lerne, dass ich ja sowas beheben könnte?
Na es gibt ein Handbook of Applied Property von Schneier. Das ist ein Buch, das sollte man mal verinnerlicht haben, um zumindest auf den Stand der 1990er Jahre zu kommen, was das betrifft. Und wenn man das durch hat, hat man auch schon einen ganz guten Ansatz, wo man wo nachguckt und am Ende ist es mit C immer so ein bisschen schwierig. C ist eine so hardwarenahe Programmiersprache, dass du wirklich einen guten Grund haben musst, um diese Programmiersprache zu benutzen. Und der ist meistens entweder möchtest du, dass es wirklich echt ganz doll schnell ist und willst wirklich jeden einzelnen Tag Zyklus aus deinem Prozessor rauskitzeln. Und das zweite ist, dass du eine Bibliothek schreiben musst, die aus möglichst vielen anderen Programmiersprachen benutzt werden kann. Und deswegen, ja, dass du in C schreibst. Deswegen SSL kann man nicht oder muss man nicht unbedingt in C implementieren. Es gibt Implementierungen in anderen Hochsprachen, die vielleicht dann für Mathematiker geeignet sind und dann als Beispiele oder Schablone fungieren können für jemand anderes, der es dann nachprogrammieren möchte. Da muss man dann nicht die Syntax von C eigens erlernen und die ganzen kleinen feinen Details, was man da falsch machen kann. Deswegen such dir, also liest dir das Buch durch und such dir vielleicht irgendein anderes Projekt, wo in einer Programmiersprache, die dir vielleicht eher liegt als C, du die Möglichkeit hast, da dein mathematisches Wissen einzubringen.
Ja, du kennst ja das Projekt Kryptol. Also das ist von Galois, glaube ich, released worden vor kurzem, open source. Das wäre eine Programmiersprache, die in Haskell implementiert ist, die eben eigens zum Lernen von Krypto da ist. Aber an deinem Projekt hat halt die NSA mitgearbeitet, was halt auch nicht recht vertraueneweg erwirkt, obwohl es open source ist.
Na ja, also eine gute Anlage, ein guter Anlass, um das mal so richtig zu auditieren, oder?
Ja, das Problem ist, das Heskel ist auch schon wieder so eine Programmiersprache, die eigentlich eher für Mathematiker geschrieben worden ist. Ist das perfekt für Martin? Ja, es hat so eine Uni-Sprache, aber die ist, die übersetzt sich sehr schwer für den Normalprogrammierer.
Okay, liebe Leute, ich glaube, wir driften jetzt in eine Richtung ab, die möglicherweise zu fachspezifisch ist. Und vielleicht für Martin spannend ist. Martin, folgendes. Es gibt eine E-Mail-Adresse zu dieser Sendung, die heißt chaosradio at ccc.de. Vielleicht einfach da hinschicken und dann kann man sich vielleicht sozusagen weiterführend auseinandersetzen. Weil ich glaube, wenn wir jetzt irgendwie ausführlich über die Vor-Nachteile von C, Haskell und was es da noch so alles gibt sprechen, verlieren wir die Hörer, die möglicherweise nur die Grundlagen verstehen wollen.
Ja, das andere, was ich noch irgendwie sagen wollte, wie wird es eigentlich ausschauen, wenn solche Projekte wie Open SSL oder andere kritische Projekte auf Unis auditiert werden? Da sitzen genügend Professoren, die irgendwie intelligent sind, und in Prozemen sitzen genügend Studenten, die irgendwie Arbeitsleistung zur Verfügung stellen.
Das passiert gerade schon.
Florian explodiert gerade. Was ist los, Florian?
Also, ich komme ja nun mal von einer Universität, nur weil da viele Leute rumlaufen, die da irgendwie in der Lehre aktiv sind und die da Dinge lernen sollen. Wir haben halt das Problem, auf der einen Seite sind die Kryptologen, die das Krypto verstehen, auf der anderen Seite sind dann Programmierer. Und die müssen wir zusammenbringen. Und die sprechen unterschiedliche Sprachen. Und auch wenn wir jetzt da ganz viele Studenten dransetzen, heißt das ja nicht, dass die die Expertise haben, um dann da die Schwachstellen zu finden. Deswegen bin ich mir jetzt nicht sicher, ob das so der weiße letzter Schluss ist.
Na doch, also du musst jetzt nicht von deutschen Universitäten ausgehen.
Was ich gerade feststelle ist, es gibt total viele interessante Ansätze, wie man das machen könnte. Und es gibt immer einen guten Grund, warum es genauso nicht funktionieren kann.
Nein, das wollte ich gerade nicht sagen. Ich werde dir nicht müde, dieses Pola SSL zu erwähnen. Das ist Open Source, das ist unsere GPL-Lizenz.
Halt, du willst einen Vorschlag machen, wie man es richtig machen könnte?
Nein, das haben Leute schon richtig gemacht.
Erdgeist, das ist doch jedes Radio. Wenn ich jetzt sage, du möchtest einen Vorschlag machen, wie man es richtig machen könnte, sagst du ja.
Nein, ich sag nicht immer ja, wenn du ja sagst.
Okay, das klebt wir klären als intern und dann geht's nach den Nachrichten weiter.
Bis gleich.
Was wären die neuen Deutschpoeten ohne neue Deutschpoetinnen? Genau! Und darum kommen auch Larry und Miss Platner. Am Freitag, den 5. September mit Max Hatter und einen Tag später mit Marteria. Und jetzt auch mit Larry und Miss Platner. Und das sind immer noch nicht alle. Die neuen Deutschbrüten. Freitag, 5. und Samstag, 6. September. Live im IFA Sommergarten der Messe Berlin.
Solang es noch Karten gibt, gibt es Karten überall, wo es Karten gibt.
Im Kombi-Ticket für beide Tage oder einzeln für Freitag oder Samstag.
Die neuen Deutsch-Poeten.
Das Fritz Open-Air-Festival.
Die französische Regierung korrigiert ihre Politik. Der Grund ist der Sieg der rechtsextremen Front national bei der Europawahl. Jetzt wird das geplante Ausländerwahlrecht auf Kommunalebene doch nicht eingeführt. Präsident Hollande hatte eine entsprechende Gesetzesänderung im letzten Wahlkampf versprochen. Doch dafür fehle jetzt der Rückhalt in der Politik, hieß es aus Paris. Bei der Europawahl wurde die rechtsextreme Partei stärkste Kraft in Frankreich. Hollandes Sozialisten mussten eine Schlappe hinnehmen. Der Bürgerkrieg hat die syrische Wirtschaft völlig ruiniert. Die Bevölkerung sei verarmt. Das steht in einem Bericht der UNO. Die Arbeitslosigkeit ist demnach seit dem Jahr 2011 von 10 auf 54 Prozent hochgeschossen. Weniger als die Hälfte der Kinder in Syrien geht noch zur Schule. Beobachter schätzen, dass bis April 2014 mindestens 150.000 Menschen getötet wurden. Die Europäische Union hat ihre Sanktion gegen syrische Firmen und Vertraute von Machthaber Assad heute um ein Jahr verlängert. In der Ostukraine ist weiter gekämpft worden. Die Übergangsregierung in Kiew sagt, dass Bewaffnete in der Region Lugansk versucht haben, eine Kaserne zu stürmen. In der Stadt Donetsk sollen Milizen gegen Plünderer vorgegangen sein. Eine Bestätigung von Unabhängigen gibt es nicht. In der Nähe von Slaviansk haben pro-russische Separatisten einen Hubschrauber abgeschossen. Dabei sind 12 Soldaten der Übergangsregierung getötet worden, darunter auch ein General. YouTube muss in der Türkei wieder für alle Internetnutzer erreichbar sein. Die Sperrung der Videoplattform sei nicht rechtens, deshalb das türkische Verfassungsgericht angeordnet. Die Sperre verletzte das Recht auf freie Meinungsäußerung. Es ist die zweite Niederlage für Ministerpräsident Erdogan vor dem Verfassungsgericht. Dieses hatte bereits Anfang April entschieden, dass die Blockade von Twitter aufgehoben werden muss. Die Regierung hatte Twitter und YouTube Ende März sperren lassen, weil dort Korruptionsvorwürfe gegen Erdogan und sein Umfeld aufgetaucht waren. Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen, da haben wir in Berlin Pankow 6 und in Wannsee 7 Grad, Prenzlau 6, Brandenburg an der Havel 7 und Zieser und Forst 8 Grad. Der Himmel klart in der Nacht auf und die Temperaturen gehen runter auf 8 bis 5 Grad minimal. Morgen scheint dann auch mal die Sonne, im Tagesverlauf bilden sich Quellwolken und aus denen kann es dann auch regnen oder näher auch gewittern, dazu maximal 21 Grad. Mit zwei Meldungen aus Brandenburg, die erste von der A2, Berlin Richtung Magdeburg, zwischen Dreieck Werder und Lenin, da steht ein kaputter Laster auf der rechten Spur und A10, westlicher Berliner Ring, Richtung Dreieck Werder, der Anschluss Lest, deswegen Bauarbeiten noch bis morgen Abend gesperrt. Woche Mai, seid gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn ihr Fritz als App auf eurem Handy wollt, dann holt euch jetzt die Fritz App. Kostenlos jetzt in euren Google Play und App Store.
Im Chaos Radio, im Blue Moon sind heute zu Gast vom Chaos Computer Club der Herr Danimo. Der Florian. Und der Erdgeist. Wir sprechen heute über Open Source Software, die Sicherheit machen soll. Und haben festgestellt, das ist gar nicht so einfach. Und haben halt schon über geredet, warum ist das so krass, was für Fehler da passiert sind, wie wirken die sich auf uns aus, was sind eigentlich die Vorgehensweise, die man normalerweise so an den Tag legt, wenn man will, dass Software nochmal von Leuten angeguckt wird, damit auch wirklich sichergestellt wird, dass sie sicher ist. Und was so jetzt grob vereinfacht zusammengefasst rausgekommen ist, ist, theoretisch ist es denkbar, dass diese Software, wo der Programmiercode in der Öffentlichkeit verfügbar ist, auch entsprechend kontrolliert wird. Praktisch gibt es immer so, naja, Verpeil, ökonomische Überlegungen, wir haben was anderes zu tun. Also es gibt so sehr viel, müsste man mal, macht man aber nicht. Erdgeist meint aber so, es gibt aber schon ein Beispiel, wo das funktioniert.
Ja, es gibt da das Beispiel von der Belgischen Universität, die zwar von der Regierung gesponsert, aber sich da mal hingesetzt haben und eine Bibliothek geschrieben haben, in der alle Primitiven und die meisten Annahmen, die sich irgendwie formal beschreiben ließen, auch bewiesen worden sind, dass sie genau nur das tun und dass sie keine Sicherheitslücken beinhaltet und auch keine logischen Fehler beinhaltet. Und diese Bibliothek heißt halt Pola SSL. Und das einzige Problem daran ist, dass sie mit GPL, mit einer Lizenz daherkommt, die nicht für jeden Anwendungsfall geeignet ist. Es gibt andere Projekte. Freunde von mir schreiben in OCaml gerade eine OCaml TLS-Implementierung, die auch erstens sehr klein ist im Zeilen von Code und die sich auch sehr stark am Standard anlehnt. Die sind jetzt gerade dabei und das Problem ist, dass der Standard nicht wirklich in sich widersprüchlich ist. Der Standard ist einfach eine Beschreibung des Status Quo zu irgendeiner Zeit und sehr durchlässig und erlaubt. Ziemlich viel. Das heißt, eine Bibliothek, die genau dieses SSL oder TLS implementieren möchte, was in OpenSSL auch implementiert war, hat jetzt viele Schwierigkeiten, sich standardkonform zu verhalten. So dass es auch mit wirklich jedem Windows 95 Internet-Explorafier noch reden kann und dort sich ihre Webseiten ausliefern kann und trotzdem die schlimmsten Fehler vermeidet. Das heißt, dort abzuwägen. Auf der einen Seite den ganzen Gehirnschmalz, was die Ingenieure schon in das Formulieren des Standards gesteckt haben. Dort die Faulheit oder die Unzulänglichkeiten da irgendwie rauszuabstrahlen und das noch in Software zu gießen, ist schon eine Hirnakrobatik, wo es echt Leute braucht, die sowohl die Mathematik verstanden haben, als auch programmieren können, als auch die relevantere Literatur der letzten 20 Jahre über, wie Angriffe stattgefunden haben und was man vermeiden möchte.
Eins weiß ich sicher, ich möchte das nicht programmieren. Sagst du, das schreiben Freunde von dir. Das ist ja schön und gut, aber gibt es auch sozusagen, also ist der Plan, andere Leute sollen sich das mal angucken, ist der da jetzt auch schon Teil des Programms, haben sie sich darüber Gedanken gemacht?
Ja natürlich. Sie machen mit Absicht, machen sie es gerade noch nicht leicht in Software reinsteckbar, weil sie wollen nicht, dass es irgendjemand benutzt, bevor es nicht komplett durchgetestet und probiert ist. Aber in der Community, die sich extra der beweisbaren Software verschrieben hat, was ich finde, was ein sehr wichtiger Punkt, dass es heutzutage viele kritische Anwendungen gibt, bei denen du möchtest, dass du vorher ein ganz spezifisches, herunterformulierbares Problemfeld, was du irgendwie lösen möchtest, hast und Software, die genau deine formale Beschreibung des Problems auch implementiert. Das möchtest du für Flugzeugtechnologie, das möchtest du für Bremstechnologie in deinem Auto und das möchtest du natürlich auch für Kryptographie im Internet.
Weil dieser Begriff schon jetzt ein paar Mal gefallen ist, beweisbare Software, man kann sich das wirklich vorstellen, also vereinfacht wie eine mathematische Formel, dass man quasi die Software, ich sage mal, ausrechnen kann und dann einen mathematischen Beweis hat, das Ding macht genau das, was es soll.
Genau. Also es gibt in der Informatik gibt es so einen Satz, dass man das eigentlich nicht kann. Irgendwie im Vorfeld sagen, was Software tut, das ist das Halteproblem, weil wenn du es könntest, dann hättest du dir noch mächtigere Software geschrieben und würde in der Logikwolke explodieren, aber es gibt für die meisten Anwendungsfälle gibt es schon die Möglichkeit, in dem du einfach die Abwesenheit von bestimmten Dingen versuchst zu beweisen. Das geht schon gut genug und diese Software existiert auch und diese Software wird in der Community, die sich darum kümmert, genau solche beweisbare Software zu schreiben, auch gerade sehr gutiert, weiß gerade mal.
Wird diese Software überprüft?
Ja, diese Software wird erstens, was ich ja vorhin schon andeutete, erst mal maschinell überprüft von den Beweisern, wo du dann als allererstes hinsetzen kannst, ob die Annahmen überhaupt ordentlich formuliert worden sind. Also natürlich kannst du sagen, ich möchte gerne das und das bewiesen haben, verlagere aber jetzt das Problem deiner Logiklücken in das, was du beweisen möchtest. Aber zumindest kann man das schon dann noch, da kann man mehr Leute draufgucken lassen.
Okay, also die Forderung wäre sozusagen, wir brauchen staatliche Finanzierung und mehr Beweisbarkeit in Software oder?
Das ist wie ganz dünnes Eis auf dem Weg, aber ja, also staatliche Stellen, ich weiß nicht, ob es unbedingt staatliche Stellen sein müssen, aber ich finde, dass der Staat gerade eigentlich dieser ureigensten Aufgabe nachkommen muss. Also sie sorgen auch dafür, dass auf Autobahnen nichts rumfährt, was ins nächste Stauende rast und viele Opfermachter inzwischen sind. Die wirtschaftlichen Schäden, die entstehen können, wenn in großen Krypto-Bibliotheken Dinge platzen, sind einfach schon so...
Soli-Zuschlag für Code Review.
Ja, und es ist vor allem nicht so teuer, wie jetzt mal bundesweit einen TÜV aufzuziehen ist, irgendwie um diverse Größenordnungen teurer als dort mal... Na ja, es braucht ja gutes Projektmanagement und es muss Leute geben, die mit so einer Rasselbande von verrückten Nerds irgendwie klarkommen, die die managen können, die dann auch Erwartungsmanagement hinbekommen. Und so eine von den Ideen ist einfach kleinere Mengen Geld immer in wohldosierten Häppchen rauszugeben und das dann oft machen zu lassen. Also man sagt einfach von den 100 Projekten, gehe ich mal davon aus, dass 90% wie eh nichts werden, aber von den 10% finden wir dann raus, dass das funktioniert hat. Aber pumpen da nicht so viel Geld hin, dass es sich jetzt für Siemens oder T-Systems lohnt, Ihre Abteilung, die darauf trainiert sind, große Mengen Fördergeld abzugreifen, was ja immer das Problem ist.
Okay, aber das fülle ich mir weit, also sagen, dass man eine Art und Weise findet, wie die öffentliche Hand gerade sozusagen auch ich sag mal Freelance Open Source Programmierer fördert und sagen nicht nur große Firmen. Wie ist es denn bei den anderen, habt ihr Ideen oder Wünsche an Open Source, wie Open Source und die Community selber das besser machen könnte in Zukunft? Danimo? Im Prinzip wäre es halt wichtig sicherzustellen, dass also es ist einfach zwingend notwendig, alles das, was sicherheitskritisch ist oder was jetzt wie im Falle von Bibliotheken, die quasi indirekt sowas wie OpenSSL verwenden, dass die einfach sehr gute Tests mitbringen und auch in regelmäßigen Abständen auditiert werden. Das bedeutet also, wenn ich mir jetzt so einen Audit besorge, dann weiß ich, dass der Stand sicher ist. Wenn morgen jemand einen Komet reinkippt, dann kann das gut sein, dass der schon wieder alles kaputt macht. Das bedeutet, sowas muss in regelmäßigen Abständen passieren und möglichst auch von Leuten, die quasi eine andere Brille anhaben. Also nicht selber tief im Projekt drinstecken. Wie motiviert man solche Leute? Naja, auch wenn Florian mich dafür schlagen wird, ich finde diese Idee, letztendlich Unis damit zu beauftragen, gar nicht so schlecht. Und das passiert auch schon. Also ich kenne das, ich hatte bei einem anderen Open-Source-Projekt tatsächlich Leute von, ich glaube es war von der Ruhruni Bochum, die sind da sehr umtriebig. Und die haben tatsächlich als Hausaufgabe bekommen, nehmt euch mal ein beliebiges Open-Source-Projekt weil der geht es halt am einfachsten und haut da mal drauf rum und schaut mal, was er findet. Und die haben uns das tatsächlich gemeldet.
Also ich haue dich da jetzt nicht für, im Gegenteil.
Man kann mit dem Schein wenigen. Das finde ich super.
Das finde ich super. Da kann man auch noch Backbounty machen und den Leuten auch noch Geld dafür geben, wenn sie was finden. Das Problem daran ist halt nur, weil ich da mal jemanden draufsetze und so Studenten sich das angucken lasse, heißt das nicht, dass er sicher ist.
Nein, natürlich nicht.
Aber es ist natürlich besser als nichts, viel besser als nichts.
Genau, du musst das halt einfach ökonomisch betrachten, auch wenn es scheiße ist. Und du musst erstmal was besseres finden. Und klar, so eine staatliche Finanzierung wäre zum Beispiel eine Möglichkeit. Aber das ist ja auch selbstverstärkend. Wenn du Leute hast, die sich an sowas probieren, dann kommen da möglicherweise auch mehr Leute hinten bei raus, die in sowas wie Code Review kompetent sind.
Braucht nur zwei Sachen. Das eine ist das natürlich die Projekte, die da irgendwie plötzlich Bugreports kriegen von Leuten, die ernst nehmen und denen auch durchaus freundlich, gesonnen gegenüber reagieren und nicht sagen, jetzt haben sich schon Profis angeguckt, du hast doch keine Ahnung.
Oh nein, das ist ja nicht nur das. Im Open SSL Fall war es ja so gewesen, dass da im Vorfeld schon Leute kamen und bestimmte Dinge gefixt haben, die sich im Nachhinein immer noch als Fehler herausgestellt haben. Aber Open SSL selber, weil sie zertifiziert waren, diese FIPST-Zertifizierung, die wir vorhin angesprochen haben, ist ja von der österreichischen Regierung einmal rausgegeben, da dieser Softwarestand, der ist sicher und den kann man einsetzen für Regierungsprojekte. Und dann hat das Open SSL Projekt sich am Ende aktiv dagegen gesträubt, bestimmte Fehler zu heile zu machen, weil sie dadurch ihre Zertifizierung verloren hätten. Haben also plötzlich diametral andere Interessen als ihre Benutzer. Und das ist ein großes Problem, was du auch in Firmen hast, dass die auch ihre Software nicht updaten können, weil sie sonst ihre für den, keine Ahnung, im Radio betriebenen, hast du nicht neulich irgendwie auch noch in Windows 95 irgendwo benutzt? Das war ein XP. Dass man dort seine Server nicht updaten kann, weil man sonst die Zertifizierung verliert, wo sich da mal vor 20 Jahren eine Firma angeguckt hat, dass der Stand schon in Ordnung ist. Wenn man dann die neue Version einspielt, weil da irgendwie 100 Sicherheitslücken behoben sind, das geht einfach nicht, weil du dann neu zertifizieren musst und das kostet Geld. Und zwar meist viel Geld, weil du dann wieder eine Firma kommen lassen musst, die sich mit sowas auskennt und dir dann wieder so einen eigentlichen wertlosen Stempel ins Heft drückt.
Also ich halte fest, wertloser Stempel ist teurer als tatsächliche Codeüberprüfung. Florian, du wolltest noch was sagen?
Also wir waren ja eben noch bei den Wünschen an die Open Source Community oder so. Also ich fänd's halt total super, wenn Leute sich Code angucken, dass das, was sie dann eventuell finden oder was sie meinen, gefunden zu haben, sich dann auch Leute wirklich ernsthaft angucken. Natürlich ist es schwierig als Entwickler, wenn dann da unten jemand kommt und sagt, du hast da Blödsinn gebaut, das geht so nicht, das ist kaputt. Da muss man dann ruhig bleiben und tief durchatmen und vielleicht auch eben erklären, dass das vielleicht doch nicht kaputt ist. Und wenn er am nächsten Tag wieder kommt, ihm erklären, dass das immer noch nicht kaputt ist. Und wenn er wieder was gefunden hat, sich das immer noch ernsthaft angucken und zugeben können, dass das wirklich vielleicht jetzt kaputt war. Und was ich halt erlebt habe, du gehst irgendwo hin und sagst, das da ist potenziell ganz gefährlich, was ihr macht. Und dann wird abgewiegelt, nein, nein, das wird nicht automatisch ausgeführt und das lassen wir es nicht. Nein, das ist sicher. Und dann muss man halt argumentieren und muss zusätzlich zum Finden der Fehler auch noch argumentieren, dass das wirklich ein Fehler ist und warum das einer ist. Und das sorgt dann natürlich auch unter Umständen dafür, dass Dinge nicht so schnell behoben werden, wie man sich das vielleicht wünschen würde.
Und auf der anderen Seite kann man natürlich auch viel machen, wenn man selber einen Bug gefunden hat. Tut man sich gerade bei Open-Source-Projekten, wo man jetzt davon ausgehen kann, dass da nicht Leute sitzen, die sofort mit jedem auch durchaus etwas diffizileren Bug was anfangen können, dass man ihnen quasi eine Erklärung dazu liefert, nicht nur was Kaputtes, sondern möglicherweise auch, wie man es besser machen kann. Es gibt durchaus Projekte, die da mit Sicherheit dankbar für sind, weil sie eben möglicherweise nur aus ein, zwei Leuten bestehen oder weil es eben Studenten im ersten Semester sind, die gesagt haben, wir machen das mal. Das ist jetzt nicht unbedingt bei, ich sag mal, sicherheitsrelevanten Projekten so, aber es gibt durchaus genügend Projekte, auch an denen man sich mal versuchen kann. Und gerade diese Projekte, wenn man halt mal üben will, dann sind die natürlich auch dankbare Ziele, weil man da möglicherweise auch mehr findet. Also im Sinne von üben. So Fahrschule.
Genau, üben. Also man kann wunderbar damit Erfahrungen sammeln, auch kurz zu verstehen und auch zu sehen, wie Softwareprojekte eigentlich funktionieren, indem man einfach mal da reinguckt und versucht, das zu verstehen.
Und am Ende gibt es immer noch die Möglichkeit, wenn sich die Programmierer eines Projekts echt anstellen und die Bugs nicht fixen, die ihnen gemeldet werden, dann gibt es immer noch die Möglichkeit einen sogenannten Fork zu veranstalten. Das heißt, man schnappt sich den Programmcode, wenn er unter einer offenen Lizenz ist und sagt, okay, ich übernehme den jetzt mal ab hier, eure Copyrights bleiben alle drin und ich mach da mal eine neue Version, vielleicht unter neuem Namen, geb euch die Credits für das, was ihr geschrieben habt, aber mach ab jetzt mal alles richtig und fix alle Bugs, die ich gefunden hab, bau noch die Features ein, die ich denke, die rein müssen, bau alle Features aus, die ich denke, dass die unsicher sind und da nicht rein gehören.
Hast du da etwa ein Beispiel dafür?
Ja, da hab ich auch ein Beispiel dafür. Da hat sich ja Just als Heartbleed auf die Welt geschlagen. Es hat sich ja das OpenBSD-Team hingesetzt und dann gesagt, da sind in dem Meldesystem für Bugs von OpenSSL sind zuweilen vier Jahre alte sehr schlimme Fehler, die nicht behoben worden sind aus den Gründen, die wir vorhin angeführt haben. Wenn die sich dagegen sträuben, die Software sicher zu machen und sich dagegen sträuben, auch den Code ordentlich zu formatieren, dass andere Leute ihn zu verstehen und wenn die Interessen nicht mehr mit denen der Community übereinstimmen, dann können sie zwar das Projekt selber noch unter dem Namen fortführen, aber das Open BST Team hat jetzt mit dem LibreSSL einen Falk von OpenSSL, also sprich eine eigene Weiterentwicklung, eine sehr radikale Weiterentwicklung angefangen, die sie da auch gerade mit Werf betreiben, dort den Code lesbar zu machen und alles rauszuwerfen, was in 1970 vielleicht noch... Alte Wechseln oder davon ausgehen.
Also das sind Computer, die noch Dampfmaschinen, nicht wirklich, aber ihr versteht, was ich sagen will. Also ich habe jetzt die zwei Stunden, das war eines der komplizierteren Chaos Radios, das gebe ich zu, was ich sagen kann, aber als Ergebnis vor allen Dingen mitnehmen ist, dass dieses ganze Code Review-Ding und Open Source-Ding auch zu einem viel größeren Teil eine soziale Komponente hat, als wenn man es vielleicht annehmen will. Es ist halt eben nicht nur Programmiercode schreiben und dann funktioniert das irgendwie, sondern man braucht eine Motivation, wenn man den Fehler gefunden hat, muss der auch angenommen werden, man muss ja besser noch eine Erklärung zuschreiben, dann kriegt man vielleicht nicht mal ein Dankeschön und so weiter und so fort. Das scheint mir alles sehr defizit und ich bin froh, dass ich das nicht selber machen muss. Mir froh ist, andere Leute das machen. Warte, ist das nicht genau das Problem? Also, falls ihr programmieren wollt, dann versucht das doch mal. Falls ihr selber Code Reviews macht, sagt mir Bescheid, wer nämlich trefft. Ich gebe euch gerne ein Bier aus, denn Dankbarkeit gebührt tatsächlich allen, die das machen. Das habe ich heute auf jeden Fall gelernt. So, zum Schluss der Sendung können wir noch mal zu dem Thema zurück, mit dem wir angefangen haben. Ganz kurz, der Christoph hat nämlich noch angerufen. Hallo Christoph.
Ja, guten Abend.
Du hattest auch noch eine Frage.
Richtig und zwar eine etwas allgemeinere. Also ich rufe an, weil ich bin Webdesigner und dadurch leider auch der einzige in meinem Bekanntenkreis mit einem Interesse an technischen Dingen, wie Verschlüsselung im Netz und ähnlichen Themen. Jedenfalls war mein bisheriges Hauptargument immer wegen dieser, da kannst du ja nichts gegen Machen einstellen, dass man halt verschlüsseln kann. Ich glaube, ich habe das Argument von Konstanze Kurz übernommen, wo sie sagte, dass wenn wenigstens 25% aller Internetbenutzer in Deutschland verschlüsseln würden, der Aufwand für die Ausspäne im Soliment steigen würde, dass sich dieses Schleppnetz da inzwischen nicht mehr lohnen. Jetzt haben halt die jüngsten Ereignisse gezeigt, dass Verschlüsselung doch nicht so sicher und zuverlässig ist, also zumindest im Bezug zu TrueCrypt. Und ich frage mich darum, wie es gerade jetzt speziell da weitergeht. Also die Überprüfungsmechanismen sind ja immer noch dieselben, ist ja Open Source. Und ja, ich frage mich einfach, was passiert denn da jetzt als nächstes?
Naja, also zwei Sachen. Also erstmal die Tatsache, dass sowas gefunden wird, zeigt ja schon mal, dass überhaupt ein erhöhtes Interesse an Verschlüsselung besteht. Insofern würde ich sagen, ja, es ist ein katastrophales Problem gewesen und es ist auch immer noch ein Problem. Aber dass wir überhaupt da schon mal sind, dass wir uns damit beschäftigen, ist erstmal schon mal ein Fortschritt. Zweite Sache, du möchtest wissen, wie es weitergeht. Aber tatsächlich ist es so, es gibt Bemühungen, kritische Software besser zu reviewen. Es gibt zum Beispiel die Lidlungs Foundation, die jetzt irgendwoher magisch von ganz vielen Softwareherstellern Geld eingesammelt hat, um eben das kritisch, sicherheitsrelevantere Software wie eben OpenSSL oder auch anderen Bibliotheken zukommen zu lassen. Und das alles war natürlich jetzt erst möglich, nachdem hier einmal der virtuelle Dampfkessel explodiert ist. In ganz großem Maße. Und ich denke, dass das auch nicht die einzige Aktion bleiben wird, sondern dass sich halt viel mehr sowohl Firmen als auch Regierungen Gedanken darüber machen werden müssen, inwieweit sie quasi dieses Defizit mit Geld, mit universitären Bemühen wie auch immer ausgleichen werden. Das heißt, wenn die Snowden-Leaks etwas gebracht haben, dass die Leute jetzt Sicherheits- oder generell Software so korrigieren und durchsuchen, wie sie das eigentlich schon immer hätte sein müssen, dann muss man den Leuten erstmal auf die Finger hauen.
Ich gucke halt immer, wie das mit Microsoft ausgesehen hat für die gesamten 90er Jahre, wie sie da einfach so, Software, dieses Windows, dieser Internet Explorer, das war doch auch alles kein schöner Code. Und da mussten sie erst, bevor sie gemerkt haben, dass sie gerade so ein schlechtes Image haben, dass so dieses Gelächter der IT-Szene gewesen sind, dann haben sie ja auch mal verstanden, dass sie da große Mengen Geld drauf werfen und haben sich die gesamte Security-Forscher-Szene Europas auch zusammen eingeladen, was dazu führte, dass damals niemand OpenTracker reviewt hat. Aber auch bei Microsoft muss das ja erst mal so ein großes, böses, ohrfeigen Konzert geben, bevor die verstanden haben, dass es wichtig ist, dass ihre Software ihnen nicht links und rechts explodiert.
Ich glaube, das kann man ja Open Source kommen. Diese Verallgemeinerungen passen immer nie. Aber ich mach's jetzt trotzdem mal. Kann man ja wirklich sagen, dieser Glaube an das Magische, jeder kann in meinen Code gucken, deswegen wird das auch schon jemand tun, das muss man den Leuten anscheinend wirklich austreiben. Also das kann man sich schon mal merken für die Zukunft.
Oder schmackhafter machen, da wirklich rein zu gucken. Also diese Bug Bounty Programme sind ja schon mal, wie sowas mit Geld zu lösen. Ansonsten gibt es ja vielleicht Reputationssysteme, in denen man sich so Gummipunkte sammeln kann.
Ja, die Leute brauchen immer eine Belohnung, ne?
Gut, Christoph, vielen Dank für den Anruf. Bis dann, tschüss. So, das war dann das Chaosradio 201. Gleich kommt Flo Heiler, wird euch im Nachhalt mit Punkrock bewerfen. Die zwei Ansagen noch, man kann, wenn man sich für den Chaos Computer Club interessiert, vorbeikommen in der Marienstraße 11 in Berlin am...
Dienstag und am Donnerstag.
jeweils ab 17 Uhr.
Und es gibt eine Änderung im Chaosradio, denn ab jetzt, das hat Fritz beschlossen, wird es Chaosradio nur noch alle zwei Monate geben. Das heißt nächste Woche, nächsten Monat, würde ich hier Theresa Eysikert in Blue Moon begrüßen. Wird auch irgendwas mit Netzkrams, Digitalkrams sein, Chaosradio gibt es dann bei Fritz wieder in zwei Monaten, aber es soll trotzdem weitergehen. Es wird also auch im nächsten Monat eins geben, das dann halt nicht hier. Information dazu unter chaosradio.ccc.de. Die Sendung gibt es als Podcast gleich, was heißt gleich im Laufe der Nacht, auf fritz.de, irgendwann dann möglicherweise auch auf chaosradio.ccc.de, da werden sich dann entsprechend Leute darum kümmern. Erdgeist, Florian und Danimo waren da, vielen Dank. Dann bleibt mir eigentlich noch was zu sagen. Mein Name ist Marcus Richter, lasst euch nicht überwachen und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Back-ups.